[Music]
good evening good evening this is a
meeting of the planning and development
management committee of traffic council
my name is councillor ben hartley i'm
the chair of the committee
on my immediate left and right are
officers of the council from the
planning department the legal team and
the highways team and then on the tables
to the side on the left and the right
are members of the planning committee
who are all local councillors and i'll
introduce them as they wish to speak on
an item
first item to note is attendances and
apologies for absence i know we've had
apologies from councillor chalking and
uh counter silhouette and i'm grateful
to you for stepping in and our vice
chair councillor win stanley uh also
cannot attend and councillor maitland is
here as a substitute for councillor and
stanley i don't think there are any
other
members uh missing so uh yeah okay we'll
carry on item number two declarations of
interest so this is members to give
notice of any personal or prejudicial
interest in the nature of that interest
relating to any item on the agenda in
accordance with the adopted code of
conduct
councillor menace
it's just for the item run uh willow's
primary school i'll take myself out of
the room um i'm i'm ten years a parent
and still a parent there
thank you minis uh any other
declarations from any other members
no i've i've got one uh so the
application 26 separate road in sale
uh i i do know the applicant
um our vice chair isn't here and neither
is our opposition spokesperson
um
i would propose i'd like to
nominate that councillor walsh shacks as
the chair for the item council obviously
very experienced in plano matters former
chair of the committee um
can i
just look to members if they're content
with that
yeah
okay thank you council walsh i'm
grateful for that so i'll leave the room
on that item and uh and counselor walsh
can
preside over that application
item three is the minutes of the last
meeting
not yet not yet no yeah sorry sorry
there's no escape from the rest of the
agenda i'm afraid but uh yeah i took
three two minutes
it's the um so to receive and if
determined to approve as a correct
record the minutes of the meeting on the
uh 9th of june uh 2022
uh any members looking to to move that
any members happy yeah yep okay against
the washington councillor bunting it
happy so we'll approve those minutes as
a record of the last meeting uh item
four is questions from members of the
public so a maximum of 15 minutes will
be allocated to public questions
submitting writing to democratic
services by 4 pm on the working day
prior to the meeting questions must be
within the remit of the committee or be
relevant to items appearing on the
agenda and will be submitted in the
order in which they were received and i
don't think we've had notice of any
questions from the public
so we'll move on to item number five is
the additional information report which
was emailed around
to members earlier on today and there
are printed copies available
so just to note that additional
information for the applications there
we move on now to item number six
applications for permission to develop
just to explain the process and for each
of these applications we'll receive a
presentation from a member of the
planning committee to introduce the item
for some of the items we
made then have speakers both against and
afford a proposal so we'll hear from
those speakers uh once we've heard from
there was the
i'll then open up the debate on each
item to members of the committee and
i'll introduce them as and when they
wish to speak um we will need to take a
vote on each item by a show of hands and
there may be more than one vote on some
of the items
which i'll explain as we as we go
through
uh each of those items
so we'll take the applications in the
order that they're listed on the agenda
so the first application we'll consider
is application 105 642
which is north keys business park
on atlantic street in ultraingham
and to
introduce that item we'll have a
presentation from miss lowe's thank you
thank you chair
um this application relates to the north
keys business park and is the change of
use from um b2 general industrial
premises to a flexed flexible b2 and v8
storage and distribution use
and this relates to um part of the
former cartwright site on atlantic
street located within the broad heath
industrial area and as i said previously
the application site has an existing b2
general industrial use
on the slide you can see um up before
you now you can see the site edged in
red and over to the west of that and
here members will be aware of a plan an
application that came before them last
month in relation to the other parts of
the cartwright's
site which was um granted approval for
um new development and new business
units there
the site that we have before us is a
three-hectare site and is surrounded by
industrial employment and office use to
the north east and west of the site to
the south of the site is the bridgewater
canal and beyond this our residential
properties here
the application can site consists of two
industrial units a larger site a larger
building here that wraps around the site
and then a smaller
unit here the majority of the units 1 to
14 are in this large um building and one
of the units unit 15 is is located here
and there's a gross internal floor area
of 11 000 square meters and no external
alterations are proposed as part of this
application
and vehicular access um
is
to remain as existing and there are
three access points off atlantic street
into the application site and they are
here
here
and here and this is just an aerial view
so you can see those two and very large
industrial buildings on the site as
existing
units
apologies
i can see it perfectly on mine but more
the case that is not um
[Laughter]
so access points
are here
yeah
i'm here
um
if there's anything else you want me to
specifically point out and obviously
there's the two large the large building
that you can see and it wraps around a
sudden boundary that's the main building
and then the smaller building is this
one just here and that has one unit
within it
is there anything else specific
that any other members would like me to
to highlight
so on the site has existed and there's
in 44 car parking spaces
the site currently has no restrictions
on the hours of use and as part of the
development the applicant has prepared
at the hours of use from 7am to 7pm
mondays to sundays with units 14 to 12
to 14 which i'll just identify those two
it's this big block on the left-hand
side
and so you see with the greg's
directly to the north of that that large
unit there that's unit 14 13 and 12
and
that unit
and they are proposing slightly later
opening operation times of 7am until 10
pm and it's just for those for that unit
in m that i've highlighted there
so as i've said the application is
located within the broadhead
industrial area and you can see this in
relation to the site highlighted in in
purple
on the slide before you now
and as such the proposed change of use
to allow
a flexible industrial use including
storage and distribution is considered
acceptable in principle
matters such as highways heritage
residential amenity and security have
all been considered and found acceptable
appropriate to sub to conditions
and the application before you is
recommended for approval thank you
uh thank you miss lawrence we have a
speaker against this item which is uh
councillor jerome
hello cancel the driver i'm going to
come up to the um to the microphone
i know that you'll know the committee
well um
just to explain obviously councillor
jerome is uh award councillor for
altering award the site is located in
broad heath ward but as as we had with
the last application for carter it's the
nearest residences are across the canal
in altrigon ward so
welcome councillor jerome um you'll have
five minutes to speak to us and we'll
start the timer once you start speaking
thank you
[Music]
thanks chair committee members and
officers for allowing me to speak i'm
really here to echo the fears of
residents about the many uncertainties
that are present in this application
uh back in the early 1990s when the
houses on penny moore and the surrounds
were going through this committee the
cartwright group did object
they raised fears about the friction
between the their activities and the
residential immunity of those future
occupiers on the other side of the canal
as a campaigner and then council of
rollstrom over the years i received
regular you know monthly weekly
sometimes daily emails and calls from
residents regards the various levels of
pollution
the site is just a short distance across
the canal to residents of the residents
of altringham
just um 22 metres from the houses in
fact as the report mentions
though many of these complaints were
around light industrial processes on
site many were also about the noise
these could range from tunnel
announcements employees shouting alarm
signals reversing trucks radios blurring
and much more
many of these were from open air sources
rather than the buildings and residents
of course were praying that these
problems don't reoccur
we know that a few of the measures
we know that few of the measures on site
such as the acoustic fence had little or
no impact in lessening the noise
the proposal for this application is to
let units in the future we only know
that they were full was in b2 general
industrial and b8 storage and
distribution classes
only when the occupier for each unit is
decided will the issues of noise
mitigation and lighting be decided
between the applicant and the planning
team so it does leave a very cert
uncertain picture for the residents just
across the canal
i know our planning team will work hard
to find the right balance between the
competing interests of of the applicant
and resident not an easy task i also
know they have to work in the policy
framework and guidance to try and
achieve the best result
but as a
past committee member myself i know the
important role the committee plays too
the local knowledge understanding the
people of this borough and being able to
step back and consider all sides
counsellors can reject approve but also
strike compromise by improving or adding
conditions
it is really encouraging that the
applicant is offering hours of of use
restriction from seven to nine monday to
sunday um with unit 12 to 14 having
marginally later opening hours of 10.
that is welcome however taking this
application on its own merits and not
looking back to previous applications
around this site
um
this is still seven days a week that um
residents would be subjected to
uh and when speaking to residents about
this application many of them have asked
um can we not look at sunday in
particular
um could there not be any compromise
with the applicant
around the sunday opening hours this
doesn't seem a great deal to ask and i'm
wondering if the committee would
consider this matter and be willing to
find a compromise on these sunday
operating hours it wouldn't be much ask
maybe to lower them to five in the
evening or to restrict them all to seven
um and if you look at the area
surrounding most of the companies and
organizations
close early on a sunday
in this estate i don't see any reason
why this can't happen here too
so
i suppose i'm really asking to
um get the committee to consider the
possible friction that will be put down
for decades to come
and between
the operations on this side and the
residents just a very short distance
away on the other side of the canal and
whether there can be some compromise
around the sunday hours but um
thanks chairman and thanks committee for
listening thank you
thank you councillor jerome uh there was
no speaker here in favor of the
application but i think we do have a
statement to be read
uh which will be read by miss carla
thank you
thank you
this statement is read out on behalf
sorry i think my
is my microphone working yes
this statement is read out on behalf of
the applicant and their agent in support
of the application for planning
permission at north keys business park
we understand the subjections are being
raised about the proposals therefore we
wish to take this opportunity to
alleviate any concerns
as noted in the committee report the
application site has a historic b2
industrial use
this application
seeks to simply allow the use of the
site to become a flexible b2 and b8 use
the principle of development is clearly
acceptable in this location with most
buildings on this business part being
used for similar purposes
the purpose of the application is to
allow additional flexibility to support
a variety of local businesses in the
area which require b8 premises
with regards to concerns over the hours
of use it is important to note that the
site has historically operated with no
restrictions on the hours of operation
as such this application actually
provides a betterment surrounding
residents by securing restricted opening
hours
with regards to the potential for noise
disturbance the applicant has already
submitted a noise survey which has been
assessed by the council's pollution team
it was found to be acceptable in a
standard condition will ensure that an
updated noise assessment which considers
any new plant and machinery proposed
will be submitted by the applicant once
the remaining occupiers for the site are
known
it is important to remember that this
application simply seeks a change of use
of the existing buildings there are no
new buildings proposed and there is no
new external lighting proposed
no new physical development is taking
place on site
as such there will be no impact on
residential immunity and ecology
compared to the existing site and
operations
in summary this application supports the
ambitions of the trafford local plan
core strategy as the flexible use of
this site will attract new businesses
and support existing local businesses
creating economic growth attracting wood
investment and creating job
opportunities
we urge committee members to follow the
recommendation the planning officer and
approve this application without delay
uh thank you miss carly so uh i'm
looking out to members of the committee
to start the debate councillor to us
thank you chair
um it's very similar to the uh
application i had before us and the
objections are equally similar regarding
noise and
other effects on residents but
this site has been there for many years
the houses have been
30 years 35 years
they are mitigating with their hours of
use
against
what what they could do with existing
proposals
um
seven days a week is the norm nowadays
in certain businesses you have asda
aldi and
plethora of other stores
um either on the other side of atlanta
street or back onto the canal
i i can't see any
reason for objects into this there's
proposal being passed and i'm quite
happy to
at this early stage propose that we
accept the officer's recommendation
thank you council thomas councillor
wetton
thank you i'm prepared to second that
that proposal that um
we
grant this um i think
i'm reading this as largely a technical
application to keep the
businesses
within planning law
it's
one type of work changing to another
type of work it's ongoing work
and there may be some
carry on of some
noise but that's the type of area that
that it is
uh what
the the nearby residents do get is um
there are more controlled hours being
offered so there is actually a reduction
in the
in already a reduction in of the uh
hours of operation that are that are
likely
to take place
um
and it's uh it's a change that is
requested not an addition so
it's going from one to to the other
i think in in probably in the
um economic circumstances of that area
it's it's probably important
that they get approval to
safeguard employment prospects
in that area
and that's not a bad thing at all
um
i agree with
the previous speaker about the
we're in a seven day a week world now we
all expect to be able to go and shop on
sundays
but we also expect our shops to be full
on mondays and that means people have to
work on sundays uh particularly from
distribution depots so if you've got a
distribution
uh operation moving on this site they
may well need the facility of
operating on a sunday or they'll go and
find somewhere where they can do that
and no sundays it sounds easy enough to
say doesn't it in business terms it's
losing 52 working days
and that actually sounds very expensive
52 working days a year that sounds very
expensive to me
so um
just to repeat i'm happy to second the
recommendation for this thank you
thank you uh councillor welton
thanks chair
um i think there's there's
a lot to uh you know to appreciate in
the fact that this does have restricted
hours i know i battled long and hard to
get that for the um
for the previous for the application on
the site next door and to suddenly be
handed them on a plate makes me wonder
about the previous application um and i
think we should be grateful for that but
i do understand what counselor jerome is
is saying about sunday i mean i we
we heard it said that um aldi and uh and
asda they work on a sunday yes well they
do but they're open from uh from 10 till
4 or 11 till 5. depending on the hours
that they they choose obviously a
supermarket does need to be stocked and
that kind of thing i i appreciate that
so i mean i
would prefer it if there were some
reduced hours on the on the sunday um
uh i mean possibly a nine till uh nine
till five pm would be incredibly would
be much more humane for the residents
and give them
at least one day of break in the week if
we're going to put restricted hours on
let's make them probably properly humane
i know there are also concerns about
highways
highways issues in terms of it becoming
a distribution center um you could bring
more traffic
more noise on the site i mean i think
that's difficult to deal with at the
moment under this current application
because
we don't know what the use is going to
be we don't know who the occupant is
going to be and i'm not certain that we
have you know we as a planning committee
i don't know certainly it's our
jurisdiction to
to you know to think about those things
these are things that are going to be
affecting the streets outside not not
the use of the site so i think we're
going to have to leave that for now
though i did want to mention those
things because i know that there is you
know that they are part of the
objections the residents have have made
so yes i will be supporting this but i
would
be interested to hear if anybody else
would agree with me that we could
ask for a condition on the sunday for um
slightly shorter hours possibly nine two
or five we'll hear from the discussion
i'm only going to propose it if i hear
um substantial other support otherwise
there's no there's no point thank you
thank you welcome councilor morgan
uh thank you chair um
um i don't disagree with the principle
of industrial use on the site but in
fairness i'm not sure cancer drone did
either nor the principle of sunday
operation but actually i'm going to
second it because he's not proposed it
but um i will let him overthink about as
he knows the site better but i i i know
it well um and i've looked at my fair
share of doors in the neighborhoods that
um council jerome mentioned and i've
heard the complaints um and in my own
ward i know i've had complaints about
business use but i think probably the
one fair one i've always heard is it's
sunday mornings when things happen
before 9am it's really is a real um
infringement on people and they do fit
and
and admittedly sunday doesn't fit isn't
the same for us as it used to be in
terms of religious day but i do think
people sometimes just like a lion with
with quiet um so i certainly about
before 9am we'll be happy to second
motion um an amendment a condition sorry
um because i do think that'll be a
reasonable
suggestion thank you
thank you uh
uh i'll come to council hassan first if
that's okay thank you
all right thank you
i think in the last meeting we discussed
it is one of the largest industries
state in europe am i right
okay
and this industrial state is already
existing there
so number two i'm very much agreed with
my colleague and friend
that mathematically
52 days
uh in a year
means a lot of overheads
uh who will afford those meats i don't
think this make any sense and it is not
a retail shop it is
it is going to be a big
supply where uh needs to be supplied
every single day
and it is going to make a lot of
difference
in the economic growth of that in
innovation in trafford and economic
development and of course a lot of
employment going to be generated so i
fully support the offices
recommendations on this application
thank you
thank you councillors and uh councillor
thomas you wanted to come back thank you
just a question um with the site already
having 24-hour
operating uh facilities
could the applicant remove the
um opening hours as for onto a better
term
that is in the application
and just retain the 24 hours
as it's already it's already existing it
just
it's clarified
well yes so they they could operate now
well they do operate now under those
under those restrict well under no
restrictions
they can operate a b2 use with no hours
of restriction so that that is a valid
fallback position for members to weigh
in the balance
and
what we have in this application is the
applicant specifically asking for these
hours of use and what we're also mindful
of is the site next door where we've
granted 24-hour operations which members
also should be mindful of and
we haven't
the the noise impact assessment that's
with us is only based on those hours of
use that they've suggested the applicant
so in the future they potentially could
come back in ask to remove those hours
of use submit additional evidence in
line with what they submit what the
neighbouring um site submitted in it and
potentially 24-hour use could be
appropriate for that combined b2b use
that they're looking for here
thank you councillor bunting
thank you chairman i'm going to agree
with councillors thomas and wetton who
proposed and seconded this one i think
the applicants could if they wish to
have brought this application to make
these
changes in relation to the ba
to the b8 use without hours of operation
quite easily uh councillor jerome
mentions compromise well i think they've
already given a substantial degree of
compromise in offering voluntarily the
restricted hours that they they have
brought forward i think if this
application were before is now making
these
uh this change to the category use
without hours of operation being put in
i think that would still be a
recommended grant i can't i wouldn't i
would be quite happy to vote for that so
i think that with the restricted hours
that they've already volunteered i think
to then go further and say well okay
you've offered us
already one large substantial compromise
can we have more please er is slightly
uh pushing and pushing it a bit too far
so i'm more than happy to vote uh for
the recommendation that we've already
got from councillors thomas and wetton
i think the applicant has already
compromised and already given ground
when perhaps as i say that they didn't
really need to but they've done it
anyway to try and be good neighbours so
i thank them for that and i will be
voting in favor of officer
recommendation thank you gentlemen
thank you again members looking to speak
cancel the minister sorry
um i'm actually a fan of the i mean i
like i like the during the week the
hours i think are fine
um i think on a saturday
or some of us might you know into a
little bit of a lion on saturday i think
that's at least one of the days of the
weekend i think i think nine o'clock
start would be reasonable i don't think
we should close it on a sunday i mean
you know we do have seven day
um services but i think that
you know starting a bit later
um
don't know about finishing maybe
finishing six o'clock even
i think would be acceptable on a sunday
if they did nine to six you'd probably
get enough of that what they need to get
done
um but just something i think that
certainly in the sunday morning because
you think about the neighbors are having
this every single day from seven o'clock
all the every week
or you know every day and i just think
it's a bit much
um i i do think that it is good that
they've not you know gone for 24 hours
and i think that's great but i think it
could be a little bit better that's all
so i'll be a fan i'd be supportive of
changing the hours slightly just even at
least one day of the week thank you
thank you council menace any other
members looking to speak
uh counselor
only just to say that i actually agree
with councillor bunting on thomas i
think um they've compromised and they
could have gone for 24 hours and i think
we should decide
okay
i mean for my part what i'll just say is
you know i look through the objections
from residents who read through them all
and listen to counselor jerome's
contribution and other members um
and i think
probably the residents uh
might have in mind might have enjoyed
the fact that the site has been empty
now for some time and so there's not
going to be noise emanating from it for
the last um couple of years um and you
know the previous concerns about noise
were related to
the use by by the previous owner who
operated there
uh i think we do need to bear in mind
the fallback position that
uh
at another applicant other another
business could bring that site back into
uses beta industrial with 24 hours a day
operations
so approving this application i think
would it bring the site back into use
which which obviously provides the
economic growth benefits
and i i don't think we can really
speculate about whether
starting later on a sunday closing
earlier would have no real impact the
applicants
made the application they have
essentially agreed to these hours of
restriction
and you presumably they think they will
be able to let those units to to operate
within within those hours so i don't
think we can speculate on what impact
um there may or may not be by
restricting the hours further um
but also i actually think that you know
this application is probably going to be
of advantage to the residents i
appreciate there will be noise um i
appreciate they might prefer it if the
site remained empty but it does
secure for them uh unless and until
another application is made restricted
hours of operation rather than 24-hour
operation
and also i think um
the development proposes splitting the
splitting the buildings into units which
will then be let out
so i do think that makes it more likely
that the noise will be contained within
those units whereas i think with
cartwrights it was a big open site and a
lot of the concern was
um you know traffic moving around
shouting to each other um so i actually
think
using the site in this way
will uh hopefully mean less less
disruption by way of noise to to
residents
um
i know highways was also mentioned but i
think i mean the test is is well set out
in the reports and there's been no
objection i don't think from the
from the highways authority
um
the parking spaces
look like a concern to me at first
reading but i think that's adequately
dealt with by by the condition which
requires a parking services plan when
they know who those units are going to
be to be left to
um
so so for my part i i
i don't think we we we can require a
condition uh that
that requires stricter hours of
operation than those which the applicant
have agreed to
um but i'll i'll pause there and uh i'll
see if councillor welton wants to
continue with his suggestion of sunday
hours
as we've had a little bit of support i
shall
test the room and i would uh
offer a
council of ministers suggestion of a
nine till nine till six working hours on
the sunday um as a uh as a condition
um
if i can propose that
a second
okay so ministry happened a second
shall we vote then on whether
we want to amend that condition around
the ira's operation to nine till six on
a sunday
uh
yeah of course
um just remind the committee that if
you're going to do that there should be
technical evidence and there is none and
you should also bear in mind consistency
and fairness with the other application
as well thank you
okay any other members looking to speak
having heard no advice no okay we'll
we'll go to the vote then on amending
the condition around the areas of
operation so that
uh it's nine til six opening hours on a
sunday uh otherwise uh unchanged uh
members in favor of changing that
condition if you could raise your hand
please
[Music]
okay
and members against amending that
condition please
[Music]
okay so that uh motion is not carried so
um the conditions uh remain the same as
as proposed uh in the report um
if we vote now on on that on the
application so that is whether to
approve the application with those
conditions or not so
we start with them all members in favor
of approving the application agreeing
with office recommendation
and that is unanimous okay
thank you everybody
we'll move on now to the uh
the next application which is
application 106 722
delemia school in flixton
that item starts at page 25 in the in
the bundle that members have
and we will have an introduction first
of all from mr day
okay thank you chair um
yeah this application relates to the
proposed installation
of two air force heat pumps
at delamere primary school in flixton
just put the site
location plan on
um the application has been reported to
the planning and development management
committee
because the applicant is traffic council
and a letter of objection has been
received uh contrary to the officer
recommendation of approval
the proposed airsoft heat air source
heat pumps will be cited
adjacent to the western side elevations
of two of the schools single-story
buildings
as you can see in in red on that plan
um the letter of objection raises
concerns about the proposal's noise
immunity impacts on local residents
um just quickly running through um
you can see a more detailed plan there
and elevations showing
the position of the
two air source heat pumps
um
on the scale of them in relation to the
existing buildings
that shows the the mesh screening guard
that will be around
the the plants
um and some photographs showing where
the air source heat pumps will be cited
um so on that image it would be on the
the extreme left hand
um side
of the image so set back from
from the gable on the side elevation on
on that
one and then on this one it would be on
the main
side gable elevation between the main
building and the shed
um and that's just photographs showing
the boundary
on welaca road
to the west of the site
um it's considered that opposed air
source heat pumps would be acceptable in
terms of green belt impacts
and also in terms of design and neighbor
immunity impacts
with pollution and licensing nuisance
consulting confirming no objections
there will be no adverse impacts that
would significantly and demonstrably
outweigh the benefits of granting
planning permission
when assessed against the policies of
the mppf
and it's therefore recommended that
permission is granted subject to
appropriate conditions
thank you
thank you mr day uh there are no
speakers for against this item and i
don't think we have any statements to
read for or against so
uh open up the item to members of the
committee councilor walsh
thanks chair um i went to see the site
uh
last week and uh
residential property is quite a distance
away from this um
this application and the picture
shoulders is there's trees
and what are the in between so i don't
feel it's going to cause an issue and
all resident has made a representation
but
i don't see that so significant to
warrant reviews i'm very happy with the
application and move that we granted
chair thank you
thank you council walsh uh councillor
thomas
thank you chair uh echo exactly what
council walters said i know the site
extremely well
it's
lined by trees there's a field before
the trees and there's a field after the
trees before the residents
residential properties
if this wasn't traffic property it
wouldn't be before us there's no reason
in my mind to object and i second the
proposal
counselor proctor
thank you
i don't understand why anyone would
object
my son's home had an air source heat
pump they're not noisy
and we need to move to cleaner
technologies
so for me this is absolute no-brainer to
approve
thank you
thank you councillor maitland
thanks chair i agree with um with
everybody else um i went to see this
today as well and the trees the tree
lines and the shrubs that are there i'm
sure is going to
to be honest
what sort of a noise do these things
make i have no idea
er cancel the proxy looks actually wow
the answer it's like a bridge
you hear um the noise of air being
sucked in
and the noise that you get at the back
of the fridge just a bit bigger it's
they're not that noisy
thank you
it's outside yeah
no
to add apart from the fact that i did i
have suggested to ms coley that we uh
that we actually go on a visit to to see
some
air source heat pumps um on um you know
on a
maybe
a more substantial basis you know where
there's several of them in a in a row so
we can actually get an idea of what they
sound like and that would be i think
that'd be a really good thing for the
committee to do
a nice outing
yeah i mean if if members are um willing
we could do a bit of an outcomes touring
in september and maybe taking some air
some of those things
um
when we when we do so so yeah i can we
can we can uh arrange that
yeah i think that's a really good
suggestion councillor welton i think uh
there's obviously some evidence around
the
the noise impact and it talks about 40
decibels 45 decibels but it'd be good to
get a sense of what that what that means
i think for members yeah it's a good
suggestion any other members looking to
speak on this item
no okay it's been moving to seconded
that we
approve permission uh in accordance with
the officer recommendation so if we
could
uh vote on that motion please all those
in favor
and that is unanimous thank you everyone
so that application is uh approved
okay yeah
so we will use the microphones and if
speakers just make sure the microphone
is is close to them when they speak and
then that will help to amplify the noise
uh
our next item is 26 separate close in
sale so
um i'm going to hand over the chair to
council walsh at this point and leave
the room thank you
okay um
page 35 of your papers 26 said very
close
um
the speaker against the application and
the speaker
for the application will take the
instructions take the introduction first
as usual
i get my routine wrong but we'll look
forward to introduction thank you
thank you chair
um
just put the site location plan on again
um so this application relates to
the proposed erection of a first floor
rear extension at 26 said were close in
sale
the application has been called into the
planning and development management
committee by councillor holden
who has raised concerns regarding over
development of the site
and the impact on the immunity of the
neighboring property at number nine
carnegie close
so on the site plan that's the property
directly
to the north
of the application site edged red
a previous planning application
104 501 hha 21 for the erection of the
first floor rear extension at this
property was refused
on the 24th of july
2021.
on the grounds that the extension would
have an unacceptable overbearing and
overshadowing impact
on the rear garden of nine carnegie
close
and a subsequent appeal against that
decision was dismissed by the planning
inspectorate
on the 22nd of december 2021
the proposed first floor rear extension
has since been amended in this
application
um
sorry it's been amended
in comparison with the previous
application
and reducing width to ensure that a
minimum separation distance of 3.5
meters is to be retained
between the proposed extension and the
shared boundary with number nine
carnegie close
whereas previously the distance was 1.5
meters
i'm just running through the plans you
can see the
footprint of the extension there
hatched
in red
at the rear of the application property
sorry it's red on my phone
the hatched the hatched
area anyway hatchling grey
um
the proposed layout plans oh sorry
that's existing layout plans
existing elevations
proposed layout plan
yeah unfortunately it's a lot clearer on
my
plan on the screen where it's in red but
um
you can see the first world extension
with the two bedrooms
there
and the elevations
um
so you can see on that rear elevation
that the
extension is
set away from the
the
existing side elevation of the property
and just some photographs that's showing
the rear elevation of the application
property
the rear elevation again
angled slightly towards the garden of
nine carnegie close
and again um looking towards um
the boundary with 24
several close
i'm looking towards the garden of nine
carnegie close
and finally there's a google
maps image um viewed
from the north from the direction of
nine carnegie close looking towards the
application property
this is my car
and this is the
application property
okay thank you chair
okay
um
thank you
this is a statement on behalf of carl
hughes of nine carnegie close in sale
good evening please accept my apologies
that i'm unable to join you this evening
due to pre-planned holiday in addition
to my initial objection concerns which
you will already have seen i would like
to present the following considerations
following my receipt of the case
officers report
the report references the windows in the
proposed extension would not have a
direct view into my property whilst this
may not be a direct view if the occupier
was to look out of the view they can see
directly into the back of my property
and main living area which is a valid
intrusion of privacy which i feel
extremely uncomfortable with
the ref report references many points
that refer to direct view and position
of properties
however as the two properties are angled
at the rear the proposal causes a
detrimental impact to light and privacy
which i don't believe has been taken
into consideration
no other properties in the area
surrounding do this
the case officer hasn't been to view the
property prior to completing the report
and i therefore feel the way the
properties are positioned hasn't been
taken into consideration
the local council that came to view on
behalf of the case officer robert duncan
agreed that in his op opinion he could
see how this would cause an intrusion
and his recommendation to the case
officer would be to refuse permission to
use his words if this was my property i
wouldn't be happy with being overlooked
like this
the report also acknowledges that the
proposed extension will cause a lot of
loss of light and overshadowing to the
rear of my property but not significant
enough to refuse permission
i challenge this point as it's a
subjective statement as i believe this
is a significant impact as the owner
occupied the property as i regularly use
the garden as recreational space to
support with my mental well-being and
therefore feel this warrant's refusal my
ask would be that the planning committee
view the application with the view of if
you were to live in the property how
would it impact your life in terms of
privacy and loss of natural light thank
you
thank you miss coley councillor holden
would you like to step forward
take a seat and you have five minutes
thank you
thank you chair good evening committee
many of you
will remember
in fact no many of you won't because you
weren't here
some of you may remember my first ever
contribution
to the planning committee
which referred to
an extension
and in that representation
i misquoted
a
french
philosopher
who said hell is other people
in this context hell is other people's
extensions
and i have no doubt in my mind that
nobody
likes their neighbors extension plans
you will have seen it over and over
again at this committee
and this is no different
you've heard the statement from number
nine
the person who's going to have to live
with this extension
and looking at this extension whereas
what i'm going to be saying to you is
from someone who actually lives more
than a mile away
so i do hope that you can apply some
weight
to the previous statement
now from my point of view
if we look at the
the package that you've got
under the section on relevant planning
history
the last entry
refers to
in fact the original
planning application
to build this development
it was in 1999
i don't believe i don't think you will
believe that any developer at that
period
would have built anything that wasn't
right up to the maximum
space usage they can get away with
and yet here we're asking to extend and
take up some of the very limited open
space that's on there
we then move on to the representations
which you've heard
the creation the first four rear
extension would cause a lot of light and
overshadowing into the neighbor's
property
you've all visited the site
do you believe that
if you do
then you should receive you should
refuse the application
similarly given the modest size of the
garden
together with the scale of extension and
close proximity to the boundaries
you can see this picture that's
developing of a significant impact on
the life and well-being of the neighbors
property
he uses the term increased
sense of enclosure if you've seen the
site you'll appreciate what uh what he's
talking about
and the proposed elevation would
directly overlook the rear garden
this is always going to be the case that
is significant as far as the objector is
concerned
if we then move on
to the last
point before the
observation
this will be potentially the third time
i'll stress that the third time
that this property has been
significantly extended
i once heard a term used by
one of the members of this committee
wasn't even here now
and that was reverse salami slicing
where you actually want something big
but you know you're not going to get it
so go for a small one and then another
and then another
and i think that's what we have here on
the face of it
point five policy in the course strategy
requires that the development is
appropriate in the context
this is subjective i accept that
what i'm asking you as a committee
to think about is whether in fact it is
and whether it's in fact appropriate
that more space should be taken up
in item seven
there's a statement that says it's
therefore considered that it would not
have any significant additional impact
on the spaciousness of the area
you've seen the area you've visited the
area what do you think
because what i think is irrelevant it's
what you think now is important
and finally
the conclusion
the previous refusal appeal decision in
relation to application 21 has been
taken into consideration it's very
difficult
to do that
when you've had this sort of history the
situation i'm going to finish there
and throw myself
and the residents of carnegie close onto
your
sympathy and to your mercies thank you
very much
thank you council holden
um kate clarkson the applicant if you'd
like to step forward
and you have three minutes kate thank
you
thank you
you don't need to keep your finger on it
if you press it if you press the button
that you're pressing once that's it
brilliant you've got magic touch
thank you for allowing me to speak to
you
uh my name is kate and i live at 26 ed
berkeley's
i'd like to try and address the concerns
of the objectives
i don't believe that the property is
over developed there are many houses on
the estate with a similar extension to
the one that i hope to achieve and they
do it with one planning application for
a wraparound extension
one of these was completed within the
last couple of months on the estate and
there are many many similar ones to that
the objectives have had two extensions
to their property since i've lived there
and one of my direct neighbors the
brother of one of the objectors has had
an application approved only last year
to convert their house to four bedrooms
the house at the bottom of my garden has
a similar extension
the extension will not increase the
footprint of the property so will not
develop any additional land in the plot
my proposed extension is therefore in
keeping with other developments in the
estate
i believe there will not be a reduction
in the natural light the objective's
house is offset from mine and is it 90
degrees to mine
they have natural light and an
uninterrupted view across my garden and
across the garden of all my neighbors
and it will cause minimal additional
shadowing as the turn sun rotates from
the left to the right of their garden
any shadow would fall into the
wedge-shaped area of their garden offset
from their house which is not an area
they use
their garden furniture etc being
directly outside their bifold drawers
i had a light survey done for the
proposal i did last year
which showed a very small impact of
increase of shading from the proposed
extension i had then and clearly as this
extension is offset the shading will be
even less
so that is nine carnegie close
and you can see that the area of shading
is really small it's right up against
the fence and it's nowhere near
excuse me
mr armstrong um we really shouldn't be
showing a drawing to the members it
hasn't been if you're like qualified by
officers
so i would urge you not to do that thank
you
yeah so from the lights area that i had
done last year the impact in terms of
overshadowing their garden is really
minimal there's very little increase as
you've seen from the maps the apex of my
roof is much lower than many similar
properties on the estate they have this
you know two-tier
skyline mine is a low-tier skyline
the extension
will reduce their overlooking rather
than increase it if you imagine when you
look out of a window you look out and
you look to one side and you look to the
other you're looking in really a sweep
of about 45 degrees
so the further you are away
from their garden
the greater the overlooking will be
because you will they will fall within
your natural 45 degree eye line
as you move forward you find that your
45 degree eye line won't include that
garden at all you'd have to specifically
turn your head to look to see what was
happening
and why would you want to your natural
inclination is simply to look out of
your window glance from left to right
it will reduce rather than increase the
overlooking
the house and garden will be even more
peripheral than it is now
the extension therefore won't reduce
their privacy
my proposed extension therefore complies
completely with trafford's planning
requirements
um as i understand that the officers are
recommending approve although i couldn't
really hear much of what was going on
because i forgot to put my hearing aids
in which is entirely my own fault
um i would like to thank you for your
consideration of our application and
obviously i very much hope that you will
agree that it's okay
thank you
thank you very much like to return to
your seat
any members wish to speak
counselor bunting
thank you chairman um
obviously i know this area very well uh
i am one of the three ward councillors
after all
um and yes i do remember
the speech made by councillor holden on
the occasion which he he referred to um
[Music]
council holder makes a good argument and
i sort of congratulate him on
constructing what
is a whole
a well-structured argument based on uh
the facts available but i'm afraid on
this occasion counselor i can't agree
i
have
been over this application several times
and
i i do agree that the
the impact in terms of overshadowing
will be
will be negligible and will not cause a
substantial issue in relation to the uh
application in relation to the applicant
i also in terms of visual meaning
or visual intrusion which is really the
only other substantial argument
available i do agree that the
given the angles concerned the
impact will be very minimal i mean it is
not entirely unusual for
a house of one
uh well the windows of one house in the
united states is to be able to view the
garden of another you have the idea of a
completely enclosed completely private
garden where nobody can ever see into it
is unfortunately not a realistic
proposal in such an environment
and i can't and uh other and
uh i'm
i'll tightly at the point that the apple
the applicant has made that by moving it
forward you do change the angle although
i think that
is a very i think it's a very negligible
argument in terms of the actual impact
that that will have although as i say
i'm not uh not convinced that the that
the change will be uh excessively uh
onerous uh in in the first place so
given given given that point given those
points and given the fact that the the
application has been emitted from the
previous application i think the
application being amended has made a
substantial difference to that which
we're being asked to be approved i i'm
struggling to find a valid uh
objection that you that you could that
you could sustain in terms of this
except that council holden is correct
that nobody likes anyone else's
applications and that tells other people
well yes that is perhaps the case and
hell is other people's applications also
that can be the case but given the
situation here uh i i don't think
there's any any sustain substantial
argument that could be sustained and
therefore on those grounds chairman i
will be proposing that we accept officer
recommendation and grant thank you
chairman
thank you councillor bunting councillor
thomas please
uh i'll keep it brief chair uh i agree
wholeheartedly with what councillor
bunting has said and i think he was very
susceptible but by the applicant
it's just going up and it's maintaining
distances that we've approved before for
ground floor
uh and again i agree you you move
forward to look into the
uh neighboring gardens you would have to
stand a lot closer to the side of the
window to look that way
and we seem to think that everybody that
has double
uh floor extensions
have them to look out for windows which
is not the case and it's not a planning
consideration so
i'm happy to uh second the proposal i
think is a good one
thank you councillor thomas councillor
dagnol please
oh well councillor thomas has beaten me
too i was just going to say thank you to
uh councillor holden and kate for their
um
representations this evening and to say
that i would uh recommend that we move
forward and voted for it to accept the
recommendation
thank you
thank you very much councillor welton
[Music]
i was just going to say actually quite
like this extension so i don't you know
there's somebody's extension that i like
uh i think this is it actually improves
the visual appearance of the property um
you know i think it'll actually look
better at the back so whilst i
understand
uh nine carnegie's close uh his concerns
i hope that in the you know in the
future when it's built and that they'll
actually come to come to the same um
conclusion as me that it's actually a a
modest improvement to the area thank you
thank you councillor morgan
thanks chad um
yeah i'm gonna echo that a lot of people
said i really i do understand the
neighbors the neighbours comments and
the number of extensions though i and
and
i wouldn't necessarily describe it
salami slicing but it it is a very
different house than the original house
that was built there not that long ago
um but that's not a planning reason to
to reject it um i can't see any planning
grounds to reject it i mean other than
the proximity of the boundary i i'm
i would not have refused the other the
other application and um
um and in some ways i'm surprised
when it went to appeal so i'm happy to
support thank you thank you councillor
wetton
just a few comments in support of the
recommendation i think the separation
distances um
they don't look unreasonable to me
either in
the actual dimensions quoted or or on
the drawings and i think that's a an
important factor for all i think what
we've got here is a little bit of a case
of um planning application phobia
taking hold and um
you know as soon as a planning
application appears on the scene uh
people
imagine all sorts of dreadful things
happening uh to to them and to their
properties i certainly don't see that
this is a situation where that is is
happening it's to
it
it will sit very well once it's
completed
thank you anybody else wish to comment
and has it been moved and seconded
moved by council bunsen seconded by
council thomas
all those in favor of granting this
application please show
i think that's unanimous hands down
the application has been granted thank
you everybody
uh thank you everyone thank you
councillor walsh for covering that item
we'll move on now to the uh last
application under item six which is the
willow's primary school in timperley uh
application 107 7718 uh just to note
council of ministers has left the room
uh as per her declaration
earlier on um
the papers for this start on page 45 of
the bundle and we will have an
interruption from miss cowley thank you
thank you chair
this application relates to the willows
primary school on victoria road in
timperley
the application
proposes the erection of a two-story
extension to create four additional
classrooms
and ancillary facilities and to
re-provide an ict suite the extension
will be located to the rear of the
existing school building you can see
most of the extension is is there a
single story extension is also proposed
the rear elevation of the existing main
hall the single story extension will
provide a multi-purpose studio
providing additional dining space while
providing indoor pe activity space when
the hall is utilized for other functions
ancillary works were also proposed
around the site including the creation
of an additional staff car park to the
south west of the site providing 11 car
parking spaces and the reef
configuration and extension of the
existing playground just there if you
just just flick between the existing
and the proposed you can see
how that changes the works are proposed
to facilitate an increase to two form
entry
four letters of rejection have been
received from neighboring residents of
victoria road
concerns and comments received relate to
traffic generation the sighting of the
proposed car park the design of the
proposed two-story extension and the
provision of replacement trees
the proposed car park is located in an
area allocated as protected open space
no objection is being raised to this
matter of principle as it would not have
any impact on the playing fields within
the site general public access is not
available and the loss would be
outweighed by the public benefit of
providing much needed additional school
places
the key issues for consideration of the
principle of the development together
with design the impact on the immunity
of surrounding residents and highways
and parking impacts
all matters have been considered and the
proposal is considered to be
acceptable subject to appropriate
conditions and in accordance with the
development plan
as such the application is recommended
for approval thank you
uh thank you that there are no speakers
for against this item so uh
we'll open up the item for debate now
any members looking to speak on this
[Music]
councillor tell us thank you
i think it's an excellent application um
i've not had
too much opportunity to to visit the
site because of uh
being away but
reading through papers looking at the
plans and looking into us
it's going to provide much needed
educational spaces it's done quite
sympathetically
and
traffic around schools is
a complaint that i would imagine every
single one of us around this table
receives we need school places we need
to educate our children properly and i
think this can only enhance
the education of children at the willows
i think it's superb i'm happy to
propose
thank you uh councillor canola
um
i really like the plans for this i think
it actually looks quite good and i moved
that i've second that proposal that we
go with officer recommendation
thank you councillor morgan
thank you chair um i hadn't seen the
comments i cannot
speak so i was gonna second counselor
thomas but i'm gonna agree with them
both um we um absolutely need these as
um it's not in my ward but um as a south
trafford um councillor
um one of the big complaints and i'm
sure the councils have got his amount of
school places um and we
the issues about the small number of
complaints about highways um
are our issues again for which for other
schools and for issues for um
other departments of the council so i'm
happy to support thank you
thank you uh councillor proctor
[Music]
thank you um councillor canola beat me
to
second it i think it's a great plan and
i fully support it thank you
thank you councillor wetton please
thank you um
it's a it's a good application and one
that i intend to support i just wanted
to make the comment really that if you
look at the representations i know it's
only four
objections but
they
it's all about
car parking and traffic and whatnot and
there doesn't seem to be a recognition
there or what um the positive side of
this application for for the community
those those very people no doubt their
families and friends local families and
friends will benefit from from this uh
extension to this school
it's it's good to see um
a single level um school
uh adding some a second
floor
um because uh children love it uh going
up onto a higher place as a
room for learning in um so i i certainly
very much welcome the the application
and and support the recommendation
thank you ken uh councillor walsh please
thanks chair um
i think for the residents the the beef
will be about that car park and it isn't
a
a general car park it's um
it's for the staff uh
and people aren't going to be using it
throughout the day it's uh
it's when um
school closes and when school opens
and really it is modest and it
affects those residents is it victoria
road there but it's it's not so large
and uh
i think what they were saying those four
representations we should be turning
down an application
on their loss of view that they've got
there's a nice field there i was there
the other day
for a modest car park and that that's so
significant and i'm absolutely agree
with everybody particular council at
wetton this is good good for the school
good for the children particularly
and very happy to support each year
thank you
thank you uh councillor hassan
oh thank you sir
i think it is
really a good addition into the skills
and i've been to the school appeals many
years
and i've come across and observed the
parents were crying and screaming
because the children couldn't get to
school places particularly in south of
trafford
and i
fully spoke it it was a dire need
in the borough to make more more school
places because strafford is one of the
best place
in england
in regards to education and i fully
spoke
this application thank you
thank you councillor maitland
i too support the application um but i
just looking at the street and it looks
to me an ideal street to make into a
school street um you know it's uh
it's not a through road so i'm wondering
whether that could be considered with
this by the school and
and the council together
okay thank you councillor welton
uh yeah i share a similar view about
about the streets i think it's you know
in the world that we're that we're in
it's unfortunate that we're looking at
an another car park in that you know
ideally i mean i know we're adding to
the size of the school there will be
more teachers but ideally we'd be
looking to encourage the staff to to
come to school by other means and set a
and set a good example rather than
building another car park if you build
another car park it makes it easier for
people to to to drive to the school
encourages people to drive to the school
i mean it says in the planning report
that there are plentiful on street
parking spaces outside so i am a bit you
know i it is interesting that they've
you know they've easily gained approval
for this for this this car park i can
understand why they why they want it i
wonder how much use it will get because
it's you know it's a bit further away
from the school presumably everybody
will try and park in the school first
what i would like to see in this
application is a change to the actual
main entrance of the school to create a
continuous footway across it which would
eliminate which would tell us that
pedestrians have priority um you know
crossing the entrance to the school
rather than
rather than vehicles currently it says
right i'm a vehicle i get to drive
driving you know here you know i have
priority over pedestrians i think that
that's the kind of thing we really need
to be reversing and it would be great to
see in future applications like this
that those kind of things were taken
into consideration
um at the same time whilst there was
work being done um but i will be
supporting this the work
the application you know the actual
development within the school grounds is
fantastic and
and i i really wish all the kids
well who get to use it in future years
because it's going to be great thank you
thank you council bunting
up until now chairman had agreed with
what my colleagues had to say i must
admit uh
that's the son of two teachers i find it
slightly ridiculous to
argue that teachers survive at school on
on the bus or by public transport or on
a bike i used to watch my parents
stagger home
weighed down by the uh ridiculous number
of books they had to bring home each
evening to spend several hours uh
working on and marking and what have you
so the idea that they're not going to
drive to work quite frankly that's a
nonsense that's a non-starter so
the car park is entirely necessary and
completely justified um i'm more than
happy with that so i can't agree with
the comments that have come
come later yes the school is very
welcome okay the design could be a
little bit better but then again that's
probably the argument you could make
across many of the schools schools are
hardly famed for being things of beauty
but then again they're sort of basic
functional boxes so that's fairly normal
uh but the argument that uh yeah you're
going to have all your teaching staff
arriving on the bus and then trying to
take all the stuff they've got to go
home with them at the end of the evening
uh so that they'd need to have some sort
of hand cart to
take it home with it it'd be ridiculous
so the car park is entirely justified
perfectly reasonable and that's why it's
in the in the plans that the officers
have recommended to grant and i'm more
than happy with that thank you chairman
thank you council of hunting councillor
welton did you want to come back uh just
to point out that my mother was a
teacher and a deputy head teacher she
cycled to school and carried all her
books home on her bike thank you
thank you councillor welton uh
yeah
well my wife's a teacher and uh i fully
appreciate the contributions that have
been that have been uh that has been
made on that
some teachers can cycle school but but
some i think uh can't for a number of
reasons um and actually i think i do
think the extra car park
um
is gonna benefit residents because i
think they'd probably prefer staff to be
using that car and then parking on the
street uh i like i like councilman's
idea about school street and that's
something that um the residents can
explore and i'm sure local water
councillors can can assist them with
that um
i would just say briefly i i think this
is a really good scheme
the design isn't amazing but it's it's a
good design it um
it's got good credentials good climate
credentials i think in terms of the
design
the pv array charging points and i also
think it's worth mentioning it's got a
good level of accessibility with a lift
and circulation points
and accessible parking
and
i take on board come to the welton's
point about the continuous pavement um
and that might be something the school
can consider but this does improve
things for pedestrians because the
existing car park uh has some spaces
removed i think to provide a protected
footwear so i i think this is a really
good scheme happy to support it um and
uh councillor thomas sorry just one
point on the school streets i've got two
in my ward both on very small cordless
acts they work brilliantly it keeps the
children safe and i think going forward
we'll see them rolled out across the
borough so yeah the school street is an
excellent idea
thank you uh that's yeah really good to
hear so it has been moved in a second
into it we
uh approved permission uh in accordance
with the office of recommendation
um so i think we'll move to the vote on
that all those in favor of approval if
you please indicate
uh
and uh
councillor bunting are you uh sorry yeah
yeah sorry
uh thank you that is yeah unanimous
thank you
so that application is approved so that
brings us to the
end of item six the application so we're
going to move on now to um
item number seven uh which is the member
update
uh on the appeal by aker manchester
limited relating to city point 701
chester rome to holmby road
we're going to start with a presentation
from mr loves thank you
well it's more of a quick
rather than a presentation of
visuals thank you and the report has
been brought before members following
the resolution made at the june
committee members voted to give further
consideration to the reasons for refusal
reasons for refusal in relation to the
appeal at the city point site at the
same committee members agreed to amend
the reason for refusal 3 and delete
reference to the loss of footwear and
subsequent impact on pedestrian safety
and since that committee officers have
attended a site visit with a number of
members where the scheme was discussed
further in terms of
its position and citing on on the actual
site
as we've discussed previously council
advice has been has raised concerns that
the council could have significant costs
awarded against it due to unreasonable
behavior in respect of this appeal
the officer report and sets out the
position in respect to each of those
reasons and provides the previous
officer reports and the appeal decision
decision are appended
and the advancement of the civic quarter
aap through examination in april 2020
this year after this decision was made
into main modification and intermittent
modifications and the effect of its
policies comprise a material change in
planning circumstances which now should
be given substantial weight and when we
take this through to the appeal
so following members further
consideration and should members be so
minded if authorization is sought to
amend and or remove any of the um
reasons for refusal in the up and coming
appeal at the site if members um
decide so thank you
thank you mrs um so there are no
speakers on this item because the appeal
is is in the hands of the inspector
um
it's an unusual item so uh grateful to
members for reading through the papers
particularly those uh newer members who
may not sit on the committee when we
considered both the applications for
this site
so
this isn't a
full reconsideration of the application
we're not able to do that
we're only considering um whether we
want to
stick with all the reasons that we gave
for refusal um whether we want to
withdraw any of those or amend any of
those so
i think comments from members need to be
uh constrained to to those three reasons
for refusal counsellor morgan yeah
thank you jeff it's because it's a
question so if we remove
all of the reasons for
refusal in the first place and i i i
wasn't actually at the meeting where we
we decided this back in back in march
um
what would that mean because we've got
no reasons to to refuse them
and basically what that means then is we
don't um
advance any um defense of of the um of
the of the reasons for refusal and all
we'll do is we'll agree conditions in a
section 106 with the appellant and that
will all go to the inspector and the
inspector will then weigh
um
and make their own judgment on on the
application
and as someone who is not a planning
expert
are we effectively saying
then
what are we indicating to the inspector
in that sort of regard
so we're we're we're obviously
by not advancing a defense of those
reasons we are reconsidering our
position could we what we would need to
do to defend those reasons is
um advance evidence accurate evidence to
back up those reasons
if members when members look at this
they decide that we don't have that or
that we do have that that that that's
something that i think is for discussion
today but if we don't
and if we remove the reasons for refusal
that's because we don't have evidence to
back to back that up and that's what the
inspector will take on that but the
decision is now with the inspector to to
to take their own judgment on the merits
of the case
[Music]
thank you mrs
a question i had which which i i know
the answer to is um similar to your
schedule morgan if we took out two of
the reasons and we're left with one uh
that
still gives a reason refusal
for refusal which
would allow us to continue with the
appeal if you know if so advised so um
councillor
wetton did you have a question
yeah i did it's based on on my
of my years on this council i've spent
quite a lot of them on this committee
and this is the first time i've
experienced anything like this and i was
quite intrigued in reading the
um
the report um
and it seems to me that it opens up a
whole new
um
aspect of the planning
committee really
is this a new
um
method by an applicant who's
been
thwarted or is
is this just um
you know playing the game and it's not
been played here recently
this hasn't been this this is on on
putting forward our on putting together
our defense for the appeal we engage
with cancel and that council advice was
shared with with members named at the
previous um applica at previous
committee and what that council advice
um set out is that the council is at
significant risk of
a cost award against them because the
reasons for refusal potentially
conflicted with as i said in the report
the previous inspector's decision or
that there was limited or no evidence to
back up those those um
those reasons for refusal um so so
it's not the applicant asking us to do
this this is based on us trying to work
on how to defend the appeal
[Music]
the clear the applicant's very
aware of our vulnerability
in this
i think miss carly wants to comment i
mean i'd imagine so if they're if
they're advised on on the appeal yeah i
just wanted to comment more generally on
on the process um
this council hasn't done this um much uh
very often though we have
um changed reasons for refusal
um
as a committee twice relatively recently
in the little
inquiry we decided not to pursue the um
the reasons for refusal because there
was a subsequent application that was
then granted uh and the
appellant in that case changed the plans
for the appeal to the granted
application so we we
made the decision not to pursue that
that was fine that went ahead and again
we um we just dealt with conditions in a
section 106. in the b and q appeal we uh
officers actually brought an extra
reason for refusal to the committee in
terms of noise um at a late stage
because of some late evidence that
that had arisen
um and the
in that particular
case uh we we pursued that reason for
refusal and indeed the appeal was
dismissed on those grounds so it can
work in both ways i think
why members are seeing this more
regularly more recently is because
we are having a lot more big appeals you
know we i don't think we'd had a public
inquiry um before the uh warburton lane
one for for some several years
but with the larger applications and
with the stakes being higher and with
the position we're taking on on
affordable housing viability and and
design
we are being challenged more we are
winning those appeals but we are being
challenged more
equally where we don't think we will win
those appeals then
as officers it's our duty to advise the
committee
you can
you know it is up to the committee to do
whatever they will with that information
um but we should
we should tell you
thank you
thank you uh councillor canelo do you
have a question
yeah
you kind of answered it then because it
felt a bit like uh bullying tactics but
i wanted to make sure with you that you
felt that we should go with um i know
you've pulled
subject to legal we should go with it
because it feels like and having visited
the site
it's difficult um
for us
to
appeal
to fight it really and um and i'm
worried about the significant cost that
that could bring so
i think we should go with the officers
recommendations on this subject to legal
okay uh do any other members have a
question about the process
councilor maitland here
well my question is um i i thought there
was i can only see issues around parking
and valid parking and what have you um i
thought there was
an issue about overlooking as well on
hornby road
yeah there is what i was going to
suggest if if members have um
questions about the item and why it's
come to the committee i think i think we
can deal with those now and we've had
some
some useful questions and you know and
answers
what i'd like to suggest is is it's been
suggested that we look at the reasons
for refusal
and
decide whether we want to withdraw any
of those or amend any of those so
what i'm going to suggest is that we
look at each of those reasons in turn
and that will keep our discussion to
what we need to discuss which is the
reasons for refusal so i think um
yeah miss miss loads of just
getting them up on screen so that you
can see them but they're in the
in the main report on the second page
of the report uh paragraph two
the reasons for refusal are set out
there so there are three reasons
essentially so
um i suggest we take them in turn and
and start with the the first reason for
refusal which is to do with
uh design being out of keeping with the
surrounding area uh impacts on the
street scene
um
so do any members want to
contribute on that reason for refusal
whether they think that should
stand or we should uh
change talking about uh i'll come to
councillor walsh first i know you had a
hand up earlier thanks chair
um
so i've been away from planning
committee for a few years chair
and um
you asked for questions earlier on this
is this isn't a question and i think i
said what i'm going to say i'm going to
say at the last committee meeting no
members some members didn't agree with
me
but i'm really worried about going back
when you've made a decision
and and first pre arguably someone like
myself who it wasn't part of the
original decision
to go back and revisit and then start
removing reasons for refusal
and it really does concern me and uh
i think
councilor wetton was a loser
why have we got a planning committee
what what why why don't we just delegate
everything to the offices and i think
that's the road we're going down it does
worry me
um
i think that first reason for refusal
refusal stacks up i'm sure the officers
disagree with me
i represent this area this is in my ward
it's actually
humbly and bala were neighbors of this
town hall of this council
and
i think all the council's on planning
committee no we look after our neighbors
and we have planning decisions
we keep it civil when when we're
discussing applications
the height of this building was what was
proposed at this application
will have a detrimental impact on those
residents and i know it talks about
a landmark building talks about a
landmark well i think the building that
there is there at the moment is a
landmark building and we talk about a
per processional parade i think we talk
about
people walk from the metrolink go to the
football or the cricket and it's a
tourist attraction we want to make it
the best we can the best experience for
everybody
but i don't think a landmark building
needs to be 16 stories high i don't
think i've i've looked around today and
i've seen plenty of buildings that are
landmark buildings and they're not 16
stories
and these are the buildings that are
around he talks about in the report
there's a
there's a other building in the area
there are tall buildings the bruntwood
building the buildings on talbot road
hotel football but they're not next door
to residential property that is the that
is the reality
right next to residential property
so
so it would result in a police chair it
would result in a dominant and obtrusive
form of development it will do
these other bigger buildings don't have
residential property terrorist
residential property nearby
and i'm very very supportive of that
reason to refuse this chair and you can
see where my thinking is going it
applies
to the other application that's coming
down the line i don't want to remove
that share that
those are my reasons and
if members want to agree with that
that's fine but i have to say that chair
thank you very much
thank you thank you councillor wells um
yeah my reason for for for wanting to
just try and interrupt is we we so we're
focusing on the first reason for refusal
here and i think
i think your comments related partly to
that but partly to the residential
amenity which is which is that which is
the second reason so
the first one is about the height and
the design
and its impact on the on the street
scene and the character of the area um
but i know some of your comments uh did
relate to that
um and
this appeal is is against their refusal
of the
the second application if you like which
is which is 12-story maximum 12-story uh
hotel um
so uh sorry with that oh counselor
diagonal do you want to comment on the
on the first reason for refusal please
um
slightly reluctant to say what i'm going
to say now because
councillor walsh does represent the area
and and for him
as for all of us particularly in the
areas that we represent
we are looking to the um
amenity of our residents
and i appreciate that this is um
in that respect really quite a difficult
one so when when we went out to look at
the building site
um
it almost is a matter of orientation you
look out onto the main road and you see
that it doesn't seem to be
the wrong place for that building
necessarily it seems that the main road
um
requires
some improvement that the building
that's there currently is unattractive
in the scheme of things and the
buildings that you can see standing
literally on the site and there are a
number of tall buildings there
it really is only
um when you stand at the back of the
building and you see the context there
which is that one residential road
um
so
i understand
and and completely understand and
and support council while she's
concerned for those residents who live
on that road
but i also look at it as an area of
traffic that are significantly visited
that's that's important that gets a lot
of footfall through it from visitors and
can see
that the area does need improvement and
that
the new building does offer that
improvement um
especially now there has been some
compromise on the height
um
so it really is
literally a physical matter of
perspective it depends almost which way
you're looking whether or not you find
that that building is an appropriate
place
um
and i appreciate that it has
difficulties i also think
looking forward in time and backwards in
time and now we're going to go on to the
other issues apart from the height of
the building
um
in terms of things like parking again
looking into the future rather than
looking to the current state and and the
past
we are hopeful that parking will be less
of an issue we are hopeful that um
public transport will be used and it
does seem reasonably well situated that
doesn't seem completely unrealistic in
the situation that the building is
so i felt quite differently after i'd
been and stood and locked on the site
just as somebody who
is charged with considering whether or
not this is an appropriate place for a
building of the scale and this usage and
it seemed to me that
there was definitely an argument for it
although i very much appreciate why we
reached the decision that we reached
last time
um so i know that isn't particularly
helpful but you know that is the nature
of this difficult conversation is that
we did reach a conclusion
and i appreciate that people consider
that we are going back on a decision
made but actually i feel better informed
and i feel that there have been more
there have been changes
that
justify my shifting a point of view
although i'm still very interested to
hear what everybody's got to say
so
i don't think it's as cut and dried as
we perhaps thought
um
and i do think there are some definite
advantages to trafford as a whole
having this building and
looking better and being having better
facilities than we're perhaps fully
appreciated
um and
i feel like the residents on hornby road
i have every sympathy for them
but it seems like a street stuck in a
small space of time
that
it's really difficult to manage because
it is where it is
so anyway there you are that's my
thought having been looked at it was uh
it was very enlightening thank you
thank you uh councillor bunting
thank you chairman i think i've well
recently i've been to this site at least
three times um i'm still trying to get
over the last
time i went there
sight of viewing those shorts chairman
will be haunting me for
many years to come uh yeah i'm probably
gonna need some counselling to get over
at some point in the future
but being slightly more serious i
i agree i i agree with the council welsh
council boss has got a great deal of
experience on this committee
i'm not sure which one of us has served
more years but it's uh not far off
between the two of us
um
and if this designed by external
appearance scale height massing
is not unduly dominant
then i'm not entirely certain what
building could
ever be
if we are saying this criteria does not
apply in this case
then we maybe need to strike this
criteria from the record and say that we
won't be using it again because
if this isn't then i don't know what is
um
it isn't just the height that we're
talking about although that is maybe an
issue in this exact location
uh if it was a tall elegant tower which
this sure as hell ain't
then we might be able to try and work
our way around this but this is a large
lump and mass
uh its design is
not of a high quality in my opinion um
the idea that this is a a statement
building well yes it is
it says this building is ugly that's
what this build the statement is
it is a clear statement the you know
um
[Music]
so the idea that his design and his
external appearance and his scale and
massing were duly
unduly dominant
if it isn't please show me a building
that is
because this is this
this
section and i'm only referring to that
point first point section i'm sure we'll
move on to the other items in a moment
but if this first paragraph
i appreciate it's a standard paragraph
but it could have been written
specifically to talk about this building
it you know if we're not going to refuse
on this kind of thing we may as well put
a
sign on the outside of this building you
know planning department closed bill
what the hell do you like
um how can this not be overdone when we
are not just talking about the number of
stories
this is about the design and the
external appearance and the height and
the massing and whether it will be
unduly dominant
that's what we're saying here not just
how many stories is it i know what
there's a building not that far away
that's a similar number of stories
this is about the overall design and the
external appearance and i agree
absolutely with council walsh this isn't
my ward
my ward is some distance away my
residents won't be affected by this in
one iota unless they happen to live or
work anywhere near here or perhaps go to
manchester united occasionally when
they're going to have to look at it but
i stand by
the the residents who will be on a daily
on a daily basis impacted as both those
who are residents in this area and those
who have to come to this area which of
course includes me thank you chairman
okay thank you councillor bunting uh
council minister did you want to say
something on the first reason yeah yeah
um well i was going to say in the yeah
the first reason i'm afraid
in time i i still agree with it entirely
i i i remember i remember the horrible
crown thing that that there's put on the
top and the argument about how many
flaws it was and what not i'm not gonna
go back there but it's it's and it's
it's an unattractive i won't use the
horrible wording for it but uh is an
extremely unattractive building um i
think that it is too big um even if we
go you know uh beauties in the eyes and
behold it is um too big and it's not the
right it's not the right um
design the right
size um redevelopment i don't have a
problem i think it's the it's the it's
the wrong size um
it's not the right thing to be there
um i i i i the parking i was less
concerned about i remember when it came
i was less concerned about parking
because of you know the where it is and
i thought that the park car parking we
don't really need that much car parking
hopefully people will stop driving
everywhere um
so that was i was less concerned but the
first the first reasons is still there i
don't see i'm not i don't want it taken
out and this idea of bringing it back
and bringing it back i mean
it does literally i do then wonder what
are we doing here as a planning
committee you know coming
they're just gonna like these things are
kind of come back again it's the first
time i've seen it but i've not been here
that as long as
these two uh next to me but you know i
it is a dangerous precedent to be
setting bringing it back because because
i don't know that you don't agree with
us or whatever i don't know i'm i'm not
i'm not changing my mind okay thank you
so i don't i don't think we need to
cover
why is it that before the committee
because i appreciate not all members
were here but we agreed that the last
meeting we agreed we would
review the reasons for refusal so that
decision has been gone um
uh but uh yeah uh hear your comments
about about the first reason for refusal
we'll come back to the parking uh if if
we may um
so uh
um
council thomas on the on the first
reason i'll come to you in a moment
what i'd like to throw in ever may is
obviously the members who have spoken
very much
do not want to
withdraw that reason for refusal
um one of the things that is touched on
directly by the inspector
who heard the appeal from from the first
application was about the height
and
what he said was a building of that
height 16 stories on that site would be
acceptable so for my part i think
there's a clear problem with
referencing the height as a reason for
refusal in terms of the design so
um what i'd like to suggest if members
are our
support of this is that we could remove
the reference to height in the first
reason because i think we're gonna hide
into nothing there effectively so i'll
just put that out there uh canceller
thomas i'll come to you know thank you
chair
without going back over the reasons at
the committee meeting that this was
brought to first
the debate was long
and i think we were virtually unanimous
from
correct me if i'm wrong
to include
the first reason for refusal
as a committee
i'm quite happy to remove the height
because
can we put the thing back up on the
screen please
thank you
sorry i know you use your computer as
well so i'm pleased to hear that
but if we take the height out of the
design
and i'm aware of comments that were made
after the last meeting regarding how
we
described our opinions of the the the
buildings that come before us
the design stands out like a sore thumb
external appearance does not fit in with
the uh surrounding area
the scale
i don't particularly like the scale uh
and massing it is very obtrusive it's on
julie dorman on that corner i am aware
of the building that that is there now
that is not an l shape it doesn't go
around the corner and it doesn't take up
parts of warwick road which this one
does so
the proposed development does have a
detrimental impact on the character and
visual appearance of the street scene
and surrounding area
therefore consider the proposed
development does not represent good
design and would fail to comply with l7
that is what this democratic
committee came to a point and in lieu of
the the appeal and and
i don't get this i obviously we
shouldn't be flipping and obviously we
should make sure that when we are
bringing forward decisions and reasons
for decisions that we meet
um
paragraph seven on page three
that we aren't behaving unreasonably
and the unreasonable behavior does not
directly cause unnecessary waste expense
in the appeal program process we have
not done that in this case it was
debated at great length
the height was mentioned into it but we
can say now because if we they've taken
15 foot off it or whatever they've taken
off it
it matters not to jot in terms of the
rest of the
reasons in
number one
that we as a democratically elected
committee decided that the design and
plans that were brought before us
had
as an impact
on the area that that is in that is but
as far as i'm concerned
that substantiates the decision of the
committee on point one
at the original application stage and i
don't think that that can be deemed by
any assessor or inspector or court as
unreasonable behavior because it was
debated and we can show the debate at
length and we came to reasons that
can be
and in the opinion of the committee at
the time
was
relevant to this plan and design
that's regarding uh
proposal one uh reason one thank you
chair
thank you uh council thomas um
councillor welton next
thank you um i do have a question and i
i know we went over this before but i'm
still massively confused by the fact
that this is a 12-story build this is a
12-story building that's actually stick
16 stories high
it's not 16 stories but with this with
the brick thing on top
the crown
the height is irrelevant before we
decided sorry chad started to intrude
point of order i thought we decided the
height was irrelevant we want to remove
that
so it is a story a livable
story and then the stuff on top is not
included in the stories even though it's
there
it is included
11th floor is
restaurant is it and then 12 doors
i remember having this discussion
i'm very sorry councilmanist you were
mistaken at the committee
you really were it was
yeah unfortunately you were mistaken
i think i think you i think it was clear
for members who wrote that meeting we
covered the height of the development in
in some detail and it's it's 12 stories
in height to the top of the crown
that's the height of the building
point to order again chair we're
debating the height of the building
we've been asked if we would perhaps
consider removing that perhaps if you'd
vote on removing the height issue then
how many stores it is is irrelevant to
the discussion the height is not the
only issue for reason one for refusal we
can take that out of there
there are other things around it is not
the height and now we just have five
minutes after being told can we take
that out
that we've debated how high it is
i'm sorry it's not if we're going to
take it out fine vote it with the
committee let's remove the height issue
from the reason and we'll keep the rest
of the things in there because they're
all as relevant as the rest of them
okay thomas yeah i understand any point
i think i think i was uh maybe hesitant
in
mentioning the height but uh you know i
agree with you i think the height is
unsustainable so i would i would
certainly favor taking that out and and
my impression is you would you would
second that um so
do you do you have a comment relating to
the height cancel the diagonal because i
think council thomas's suggestion is a
good one that if we take that out that
will limit no i need to discuss just
wanted to say for the record that you
when you in your brief summer earlier
that you said that none of us were moved
to changing our minds about it or
something along those lines i might not
have been very clear but i am more
open-minded about it than i think the
other speakers were so i just like that
noting okay
yeah that that's fine i don't know some
members are not minded to move
well it's it's been moved and seconded
that we take height out of the first
reason for refusal and i think it it
will move discussion forward if we
consider that now
we have gone over the height at previous
meetings
um at some length so so i think we'll
vote on on that council bunting
to assist on this point as we said it's
the overall mass and the bulk of it not
the height per se so if we change it to
design external appearance scale and
overall mass
would that wording
suit your requirements
because it's the overall mass the height
of it combined with the fact that this
is an extremely lumpy building yeah if
this was a tall elegant tower then you
might be able to have an argument but
this is not elegant okay so
external appearance scale and overall
mass
would that suit your objectives
well councillor but kentucky miss carly
was just just advising me that
i think i think the concert we
understand the concerns about massing
that the committee have expressed and i
i think if we took out height and scale
because i don't think the complaint is
about the scale of the building the
complaint is about the massing i get
that so i i would suggest we take out
scale and height scale i will not i will
not support scale no i will not support
scale either
height
okay i'm okay one at a time
just a minute please one at a time one
at a time okay this is not a
free-for-all okay
okay i hear that there's no support for
um taking scale out okay
councillor diagonal do you have a
comment about the height no i have a
comment about um keep referring to it as
an ugly building i think we decided at
some point in the past we were going to
try and move away from our own personal
opinions of the aesthetics of a building
okay i have some sympathy with the fact
that whether this looked like an ivory
tower or it didn't it would still at
this scale
um impact on residents so i do have some
sympathy with that but however
however the aesthetics of the building
were that if it was of this scale it
would still potentially have the same
impact on residents but i just think
it's that's a bit boring and pointless
to keep describing it as ugly as a
matter of opinion because that isn't
helping us okay being pejorative let's
let's come back to residential means
let's let's go to the vote on the
proposal that we remove height from the
first reason uh i'm sensing the
committee don't want to remove scale so
we'll
we'll vote on removing height on from
the first reason
uh for refusal those members in favor of
that if you could raise your hands
please
well i think i think the implications
are if we vote for that height will no
longer appear in that reason for refusal
that's the only implications
there is one other implication in that
officers will need to
come up with an argument on all the
others
in in an appeal statement
um
[Music]
[Applause]
it's really important the members have
all the information in front of them
what what will
the reasons for refusal that remain um
will need to be the subject of a written
appeal statement which officers will
need to put together which will need to
justify each of those reasons for
refusal and justify each of those
elements of those reasons for refusal so
officers will have to write a couple of
paragraphs on design
external appearance scale
height
amassing
i think what i think what i was
suggesting to council hartley is that
height and scale are so intrinsic
that
the
concern about the extent of the building
and its
bulk
can much more easily be described
when defending the issue on on massing
so that's where my suggestion came from
so in doing this
we do have to think about each of those
elements
and how we def and how we defend it
because that's the that's the
implication we've got a job to get job
there's an officer
who's not here tonight
who's got a job to do to effectively
write this up
um and make the best case possible for
the council because that's what it is
this is the council's case it is it's
it's not theirs so
that that's why i think why we're
thinking of
of each of each of the words but we you
know whatever the committee's decision
is we will do the very best job we can
to express that um
as
again as best we can
[Music]
thank you miss carly um council thomas
did you want to just briefly thank you
chad
yeah the the reason i don't want scale
out of that is the scale is such a
different thing to height
i appreciate the the concerns about the
height certainly since
the the confusion shall we say around
how many stories it was and 12 stories
and
16. the scale of the building is how it
sits within
an area
it could be
400 meters long and two stories high
that scale would be inappropriate
i still believe that the scale of the
building in the position that it is at
is inappropriate for the corner of that
road
that that is my view on the scale and
that is my reason i don't think that the
scale
should be withdrawn from the
um reason
on reason one justin that's very helpful
because we can put that on the statement
i concur with that
thank you
thank you thomas council bunting okay so
i think i think
i think we understand why um why we
i'm sensing the committee i minded not
not to take scale out unless uh unless
anyone wants to make a case for that i i
i understand
the the concern so i'd agree with that
um
so i think i think
i'm still minded that we remove height
and i think cancer thomas sure of the
same mind so i think it's been moved and
seconded
okay so i think i think we vote then on
whether to remove
height from reason one and just the
height
from from that reason so
if we can uh
vote on that now all those in favor of
removing height please
okay and all those against removing
height please okay
so that is uh
that is carried so uh height come comes
out of reason one
um
are there are there any other comments
that members want to
make about reason one for refusal
sorry
get into the diagonal
if it was at a height of 12 stories
which it is and apparently we are okay
with
how
how could it
can you perceive of a way it would be a
satisfactory building at a height of 12
stories can you perceive of a way in
which the scale would be appropriate
i'm just interested to know
how if we're going to separate these two
things out how where it would actually
go in in real life i don't yeah i don't
i don't think we need to get into that
because i think that would be
what the sort of application could be
presented for the site so i think i
think because we're only looking at the
reasons for refusal for this application
uh and whether we want to stick with
those reasons for refusal
i don't think we need to go down the
road of looking at what building
uh might satisfy members of the
committee that that's well i'm just
interested to know it is
how we can separate out a height and
scale because i think the two things
well that's what i feel like
yeah that's why i didn't want the height
okay um
i'm quite quite happy over i'm
appreciate that we're live streaming
this and the the idea is an opinion i'm
quite happy to explain my opinion to
councillor dagnol after the meeting uh
on how i see the difference in height
and scale okay i have to do that and i
agree with you we it's not a debate for
around the table he's either yes he's in
no it's not okay and we i'm happy to
talk to you later thank you okay so we
have passed that that resolution to take
height out so um
councillor wetton i think you've been
wanting to speak for a while
yeah i just wanted to make a couple of
points to
um
set my scene a little bit and but it
does time with the point that we're on
um and that is firstly by chance i was i
was present at the committee
that first considered this this
application and i must admit that i was
quite surprised by the um the result
that came out out of it
and by the
strident tones that that
were were delivered i i didn't
see it that way and i've been thinking
about
why that is and some of it sort of ties
in with what we've been talking about
and particularly what council walsh has
made reference to
his his residence
and i think there's
because i'm i actually am looking at
this from the a56 arterial route into
the city center
and building a hotel next to
a massive football stadium next to a
very tall office building alongside
another reasonably tall office building
and a tall block of flats and that that
sort of thing so i wasn't seeing all of
this horror that that was being um
described at the the previous com
at that first
committee
and
i i i still see it the way i'm looking
at it from
an a56
point of view
it's a building that
perhaps it's a marmite building i don't
know it doesn't actually bother me i
think there's something quite clever
about the crown in in
um
creating a visual effect that perhaps
makes it look less tall than than it
actually is because you see in sky
through brickwork and that's that sort
of thing
um
the residents of
hornby close at homey road they get
they probably had a what a lot of people
think is a rough deal over the years
there was the big tesco um
issue wasn't that lawrence and that
there was
massive concerns
there
at that time about that coming in and
the effect that that was going to have
but it all but it all settled down when
i look at the angles of
of the um the actual proposal
the scheme proposed
i think it's um it's
massing has got less of an impact on on
hornby then
perhaps um his first
thought
so
i'm i'm trying to um
fully understand what quite what we're
having to do here but in but in in
describing my thoughts on it i'm hoping
to
that it will bring out more of
where we're going um with this because i
think we've
if i were to cut to the chase i think
we've got a major problem really which
is much more than a line-by-line
exercise we either want to do a deal
um
and get this sorted or or really um you
know go for a fight and it's it's and
it's one of those
i don't know the scale of monies
involved
um maybe if we didn't know the scaling
is involved it would help the community
make um a decision because we can relate
to other things that the council needs
to do
so
i mixed up
uh comments a set of comments there
chairman but i'm certainly i don't see
the horror
of this application i actually see
something that one day would probably
serve trafford very well in terms of a
um
a tax generator
and
and a new building replacing one
that's
um
probably a bit less than average
okay thank you
councillor wetton um council morgan
thank you chair um so i wasn't here for
the decision on this application back in
march i wasn't
here in june when we made the amendment
um last time i was here
when the first application which was a
taller tower which went to appeal which
was rejected by the inspector
um
and i've listened to a lot of the
comments and to be honest i made similar
comments for the first application back
three years ago
and
i
understand and share a lot of if not the
vast majority of those concerns
but
i kind of should also share a lot of the
concerns that council dagnan actually
raised and i i i
read the summary
planning circumstance and i really do
have a real concern
about that statement um i do think that
that
plan which was voted on through this
committee and i'm sure i i can't comment
if i did vote on it but maybe i probably
did um
does change the the planning
implications on this policy actually on
all of the all of the the same thing and
now we're taking out height i do think
that they are
a lot more um
gray in the the and there's a reason for
debate on those but i i have real
concerns on all of the
the the the reasons for
reasons that i voted for previously um
so i i i put that on the record but
given that change i have actually very
big reservations now about the the
reasons and um and
i i'm not saying i'm going to support
the officer recommendations i don't know
if there is enough recommendations to
support but i i certainly have
an understanding of it tonight and i
want to put that on record really if
that changes the debate
thank you councilman morgan it's a good
point about this civic quarter uh
reaction plan because we haven't we
haven't touched on that uh and that is a
material change so
uh
so i understand that
you you've got concerns about each of
the reasons for refusal let's um
let's let's
stick to the first reason if we count
for the moment uh councillor uh hassan i
think to speak
sorry i'm taking time from this
uh i'm not agreed with my
uh
consular colleague
next to me
we as counselors uh my colleague
consular gila is sitting here we've been
talking against the tallest high score
buildings in old trafford it is just on
the corner of my board and i
fully agreed
what council wash has said already and
residents are the first priority
and
and this building is not appropriate it
is covering it is on the corner of
seymour grove tarbert road and chester
road am i right
it is on the corner
and
uh yes it is
and it and
and it is really
affecting uh
on b street residents
so i i'm not in favor of this building
at least
okay
thank you councillor hassan uh
councillor procter
thank you
i've been going through
all the documents about this and
one thing jumped out at me
and it was in the comments
about the design of the building
and one of them says
cqm states any building on the site
should be no higher than eight stories
is that true and if so
yes well well yes and no a very very
early iteration of the civic quarter aap
when it was
just a
strategic regeneration framework showed
eight stories on that site but that soon
moved on um to the 12 story which is
which was in the
regulation 19
draft and the submission draft and has
gone through into the main modification
so that has progressed through all those
stages right thank you
thank you it's called account bunting
i was just going to make the point
briefly um
that i know we keep talking about the
civic quarter uh and its action plan and
maybe
yes uh there are implications for this
area in relation to maybe this is an
unintended consequence a negative
unintended consequence of a civic
quarter action plan that is perhaps not
all it was intended to be and perhaps
that action plan is
in need of some urgent reviewing given
the fact that it is
if it is to create substantial
negative impact
we cannot wish away
parts of the borough we can't say oh
well if that road wasn't there it'd all
be fine but the point is the road is
there and it can't be evaporated for the
convenience of this committee or indeed
any developer thank you chairman thank
you councilman councillor welton
um yeah i just i want to ask about this
if it caught a master plan because there
was a whole raft of changes
appeared in our inbox today suggested
changes to the
text did it not today
and some of them seem to be quite
substantial
so how
can we
be sure that none of them relate to this
to this building some of them i thought
could be interpreted as as
relate you know relating to this
application and changing the way that we
might view it it's just a bit concerning
that the ground is moving underneath our
feet in this way
i could i could explain that
certainly yes the um
so
if i roll back slightly so in
november
um
last year i think um this planning
committee approved the submission draft
of the civic quarter area action plan um
which then went forward into an
examination with a inspector um
almost in the same way as a planning
application public inquiry the inspector
looks at the plan and goes through each
of the policies and and determines
whether those policies are are the
official word is sound
um
and um
and that took place in april
coming out of that there's an exercise
to take all the inspector suggestions
all the suggestions that are uh have
been moved by um third parties at that
examination and there were only um
two third parties present um
neither of whom had any interest in this
particular site
um and to
put those into what are called main
modifications
and that that's quite a normal part of
the process and it does
quite often um
if i always lead to quite substantive
changes to the wording of policies if
you saw the core strategy
uh main modifications you know
compared to
to what was adopted you see the track
changes everywhere and it's a track
change document and as you said council
welton
they are fairly substantial changes
however
what hasn't
changed and which is why we now need to
give it substantial weight because it's
gone through examination without the
inspector
uh raising any concerns about about it
is is the
is the 12-story
um element on here
the design policies have been rewritten
and there is and but again
they don't
they they
they haven't changed so much that they
would change our consideration on this
this particular application and its
office's view and again this is only our
advice
is that
the
the moving into main modifications
makes this
is material and and makes this
more in line with what we're achieving
members might have a different view that
that's again that's that's perfect
you're perfectly entitled to to have
that but but the changes to the policies
that you've seen today are as are
expected and are a normal part of the
process and have been agreed by now by
an inspector
so so that inspector will find that
version the plan we would hope sound
because if he wasn't going to
he would have raised that examination we
would expect it would be very unusual
for him to now say
oh i'm going to go off and write my
report oh by the way council your plan's
not at all sound he we would have had
some warning of that
okay thank you we've had um
okay uh uh this uh okay thank goodness
thomas very brief chair
um we've just spent probably about 45
minutes discussing
the reasons for
whether or not we wish to keep them in
the objection
um and we've talked about how the
building looks
our opinions of this and either can we
please
ask our members just to keep it relevant
that we're looking at
are we keeping the objection in and are
we substantiating the reasons behind it
it matters not a job
how it looks what our opinion of the
building is what road you drive down to
get to it it's about these
points
we're not reviewing the whole
case again the cqm doesn't come into it
although it's a valid point about this
economy stories so we should keep it
succinct and relevant to what we're
discussing so the agenda that's the
agenda item jk yeah okay i hear what
you're saying thomas i i guess part of
the reason is is around the design
and external appearance so i can
understand why members might want to
to comment on that um
councilor morgan i know you expressed
reservations about all the reasons for
refusal um
are you minded to
propose doing anything with
the first reason in terms of removing
either a whole or parts of it
[Music]
um
goodness um
[Music]
yeah i mean i it's not it's not
necessary kind of opinion it's it's in
line with
different members will have different
opinions but
i
given the
given the
error action plan i i do have
reservations so
perhaps perhaps chair if as a way of
getting us through the debate because i
i know everyone's got a big opinion on
this i remember this the first time we
debated this um if i propose that we
remove um the
first um
reason for objection and put it to the
put it to the vote
thank you uncle morgan i'm happy to
second that uh because
i i
i do think that that reason is is not
sustainable given the
inspectors comments and and give them
what we've heard that's not to say i
like the building it's not to say there
isn't an impact on residential immunity
we'll come to that same with parking but
purely on
that first reason for refusal
uh i i don't think that's sustainable so
i'm willing to second your um proposal
council morgan so we'll go to the vote
on whether to remove the first reason
for refusal uh all members in favor of
removing that first reason for refusal
we could indicate
yeah i can read it out uh cancer it's on
the second page of the report so the
first reason for refusal is quite long
the proposed development by reason of
its design external appearance scale and
massing would result in an unduly
dominant and obtrusive form of
development which would be out of
keeping with the character of the
surrounding area as such proposed
development would have a detrimental
impact on the character and visual
appearance of the street scene under
surrounding area is therefore considered
that the proposed development does not
represent good design and would fail to
comply with policy l7 of the trafford
course strategy and the mppf
so that's the reason for refusal ah very
clear
would it fail to comply with policy i'll
save another traffic course strategy
um
i don't i don't think we want to open
that debate again because that is that
is looking at
the merits of the application and
whether
it's just that we seem to be you know
we've been asked to be
extremely contrary to the point of view
before that's all um
i find it really difficult i we are
discussing this because it will not be
approved by that our reasons won't stand
up
to the inspector is that right
yeah
that's our view yes so
we either stick with it and risk that
the financial implication as well as
um or we vote against it and
then look at the next two reasons yeah
right that's what we're signing on so
let's um
cancel welton do you have a point to
raise i'm minded to move to the vote now
unless you've got a question on the
procedure really around that i i i'm
just on the brink of changing my mind on
this so i would like to kind of express
my you know what i'm what what i'm
thinking because it may help other
people
um i think that you know if
the second point
in this application is is all
you know
it's the impact on the on the residents
is the strongest factor
for me this is
given the civic court action action plan
and everything like that this is
the more marginal one the parking is the
more marginal one number two is it is
all that's the one that's going to live
and die for going on the inspectors
comments on
on on the impact on residential
amenities point of order chad we're
talking about voting not okay
yeah
cancer welton so therefore i yeah
i would be happy to to lose number one
because i think two stands up on its own
okay let's both then on whether to
remove reason number one as as one of
the reasons for refusal so all those in
favor of that proposal please
okay and all those against that proposal
please
so that uh that is uh not carried um so
that that reason for refusal
uh remains
but let's i'm conscious at a time so can
i ask members not to repeat any points
they've made and some of the
contributions we heard were around
residential amenity which i understand
there is an overlap between the two but
there's no need to repeat those points
um and if we look at the second reason
for refusal around residential immunity
and whether we want to
make any changes to that or remove it
from my part i'd like to suggest that we
remove
the words
and result in harmful overlooking
because i don't think overlooking is
sustainable
the rest of that reason i'm more happy
with because i do appreciate the
comments that others have made around
the uh
the dominance of the building on on the
residents particularly on holmby road
councillor thomas on on the second
reason thank you chair
again
with the second reason i'm not i'm not
happy to take out overlooking because
overlooking works both ways
uh somebody in a
ground floor bedroom a council room can
overlook a large building opposite
in the other way
again i think the objection stands
perfectly i think that it is
massing too close to
residential buildings and in
in the uh in the plan and the l-shape it
has a derogatory effect on
those properties it's overbearing
over dominant
it's not not the height it's
overdominant because of the proximity to
the residential properties
and
it is detrimental to the immunity that
anyone could reasonably expect to enjoy
from a property that was there
as we've discussed earlier on a
different application the houses were
there prior to the hotel so they have to
be
seen to be looked after and again just
just to finish off on the point as it
doesn't seem to be
being made
in terms of
the detriment to the council and to
how much it may cost if we lose an
appeal
again the current position
paragraph seven
if
the council is being unreasonable
or behaved unreasonably or the
unreasonable behavior has directly
caused unnecessary waste expense in the
appeals process there is nothing that we
have discussed tonight in upholding
one and hopefully all upholding two that
is
unreasonable behavior we are applying
planning law
to what has been put in front of us
before
i appreciate that we don't like to lose
appeals and i appreciate that the
council is hard-pressed to have costly
expenses but we do not do planning law
by expenses and risk of appeal we do a
planning law based on fact
based on what is put in front of us and
the opinions of those facts to this
committee
we should not be worrying about passing
things or failing things in lieu of
appeal to the inspectorate providing
that we provide
reasonable
and
relevant
objections we can't be deemed as being
unreasonable so that is not part of this
debate this debate is about the
objections and the objections only
not about whether it looks like a
whatever it looks like whatever building
looks like it's about this these things
in a paragraph two
that we are we're debating thank you
okay council thomas thank you i think in
terms of overlooking i know you said
overlooking could work both ways but i
don't i don't think it can i think what
we mean by overlooking is the extent to
which the new development will overlook
the properties on hornby road and from
reading all the papers my understanding
is the architect was quite clever about
that and angled the windows so there
wouldn't be any overlooking um certainly
at a close distance of humvee road so
that was my reason for suggesting we
remove overlooking uh i accept that if
you're looking from one of the
properties on holmby road it has the
building has a visual impact and it
impacts an outlook um and i think if
that isn't in the reason we could we
could probably insert that i think but
we
uh we have said overbearing and over the
dominant impact so by that we would mean
you know impact on on what you see if
you're if you're on holby road basically
um respect your respect european chair
but i don't think the residents on army
road think the architect have been
clever
i don't think that's there to be okay uh
that you know that was my short hand for
for making clear that the design does
not result in any overlooking that's why
i don't think that is sustainable um
councillor morgan come to you
i'm not even
um
thank you chad um i'm gonna second your
proposal um i'm not going to go too into
depth because without giving the time
but i in
um just to second it in line with the um
advancement of the civic quarter
reaction plan i think that um i propose
we second
your proposal to remove um that point
thank you
thank you cancer morgan so it's been
moving seconded that
from the second reason for refusal we
remove
the words and result in harmful
overlooking okay so everyone clear about
that what we're voting on now so all
those in favor of removing those words
from the second reason if you could
indicate no please
okay and all those against removing that
reason
okay so that is uh that's not carried so
that remains
in the reason for refusal um
any other comments on uh it's not it's
not been
moved that
we take out that second reason all
together i don't know if any members are
minded to suggest that
opposite actually i move we keep it in
exactly as it is
so
sorry counterprocessor yeah that's
i think that's the effect so
so i don't think anyone is is moving
that we take that reason all together so
i think i think we can probably finish
on the second ground there so that stays
in um so uh we haven't had a lot of
discussion about parking so the third
reason for refusal relates to parking is
anyone have a contribution on that
cancel the proctor
thank you cher
i've read their very kind suggestion
that i can pull up in their drop-off
point
and get everything out of my vehicle and
then they'll go and park it for me in
one of their 22 parking spaces therefore
making every space accessible
what happens when those 22
spaces in a
hotel building of over
169 rooms
that maybe won't be occupied by one
person
what happens then when i pull up
and i can't park there because there's
there's no room
and then i can't park on the side roads
um i can park on double yellow lines but
only for three hours
so
i've somehow got to get from their
wonderful
off-site 100
space park i don't so
can't let's let's just stop there can't
spot because there's no proposal for a
100 site 100 spaces off-site that isn't
part of the proposal anymore
so right they've taken that out of the
proposal that i think that was maybe
part of the first proposal and it was
taken out okay um
but i understand your point about
the valet parking that they off that
they're offering
um
the additional information does say that
they will remain three dedicated
accessible spaces
so those three will only be available
for for
residents
with a disability but then in a hotel of
169 rooms
the likelihood of only three disabled
people when
at least one in ten of us
are disabled
it just makes a nonsense you can't have
a hotel that big with any 22 parking
spaces
okay so thank you i understand so so
your objection is that the the um
the the level of
parking space for
disabled uh
customers isn't sufficient and we've
we've got that in the reasons at the
moment okay thank you
so much
i was just gonna say i entirely agree
that like three spaces is is nothing um
i i mean i don't have a problem with um
uh not a lot of parking for for the the
able
um but i think you know if we're going
to have 22
22 parking spaces i think we need to
make far more than three
um which is just measly quite frankly um
for you know there are our protected
spaces so i'd want a larger proportion
for because that's what the cast parking
spaces should be really for
is um
is for the excess for accessibility
okay so yeah i understood councillor uh
thomas on the parking lot thank you
chair
where to begin there are 40 staff there
are 20 40 full-time staff 22 part-time
staff
that's
let's just round it down 51 people in
the in the building working at any one
particular time there are 22 car parking
spaces
there are 169 rooms in the building
there are 22 car parking spaces
there are 11 rooms in the building for
disabled people specifically there are
three disabled parking spaces
warrick road it gets closed off every
time there's a home you match for
manchester united there are no
there is no uh vehicular access to
warrior road
that means you can't get to the valet
parking spot that's going to be so
wonderful
um
it's country as we say in the uh
objection it's contrary to l7 and l4
spd3 parking standards and design and
the national policy framework
and ppf
okay
it's also a pipe dream to think that
everybody that goes to this hotel
because i would imagine it would be a
business hotel we'll get on the tram and
get off at warrie road and walk up there
we'd all love it to happen because it
would be very very good for the
environment but it isn't going to it's
going to be businessmen that turn up so
for meetings in manchester
drive up from wherever they come from
and drive back down
it is
sadly appallingly lacking in parking
because once the 22 spaces are gone
where they're gonna go
we're already talking in the report
about it's only metered parking between
nine and five so all what it road is
gonna be taking up where the meters are
when that's closed so it also we could
also add into that
public immunity in terms of parking
locally for residents we can add to
these things and i go again
we are not being
unreasonable in our objections we should
not be fearing a fine on or
costs on the grounds of unreasonable
behavior
this council is not doing that we are
validating
perfectly good planning reasons for
objecting to this hotel
okay okay and the debate has been
in my my opinion waited
to
[Music]
trying to get things changed and i think
that's disappointing
it's a democratic
committee
where we take the facts in front of us
and we make a decision
rightly or wrongly and we stand by that
because we've got
the officers to help us and advise us on
whether or not they are valid or invalid
and we've got what knowledge we have
that we've picked up to make those
decisions and i think we should stand by
the decisions we make
at the time as long as they're valid
okay council thomas that that point is
is is made and you've made it before
okay but we have resolved to consider
the reasons for refusal we resolved to
do that on the last occasion so i'm
minded to
allow that debate to continue and we're
considered a last reason for refusal
okay
um
i don't have any other members wanting
to speak on the parking that i can see
yeah miss curly
what does it say
there are there are hotels around and
places to stay that that um around the
country in general that are near right
next to for example train stations and
they don't have masses of parking
because the logic is people will travel
by train and they do um you know and
when you know when we say like no one's
going to turn up by train or by tram if
it's near a tram stop
that is how people are going to turn up
you know because people do turn up we'll
come come to manchester by by train
there's a piccadilly train station
there's a tram
handily right at piccadilly's train
station where you can get on the tram
and then come
and may have to change trans tram stop
but you know that's fine you can change
and come and then you're nearby the the
hotel so that i i i don't actually i
mean i literally have done this i've
i've traveled around the country like
this so i don't see it being a problem
um
that i don't have a problem with i think
that this the disabled parking is the
part where i have a problem if you've
got uh if you're saying that there are
um you know set spaces for people to be
able to more accessible rooms but you
haven't got the parking is a bit
contradictory i think those parts need
to be sorted out i don't have a massive
urge to have an enormous car park built
i just don't i think it's the wrong
direction um that we as people need to
go in so i think that part i'm happy
with but the other part i'm not
happy with does that make sense i don't
know how to change that wording if
others are minded to agree with me or
disagree with them i don't know but like
if you know how we change the wording
that is about disabled um parking is is
the main problem here um
well
yeah i guess your proposal would be we
removed that reason apart from the
um the development providing
insufficient parking for disabled
persons i i would be happy with i
personally would be happy with that and
obviously i'm sure not everyone else
doesn't agree with me thank you thanks
uh miss curling um
i'd just like to
remind members that
the three
disabled parking spaces is um policy
compliant
um so if
you think that's insufficient we need to
change the policy
we can't resist this planning
application on the on the basis of of
that so
i do think there is a significant risk
that would be seen to be unreasonable
because our own policies
whatever you might think of them say
that three spaces is is sufficient so we
cannot reasonably ask for more um
councillor hunting council menace you've
spoken already on this so i'm going to
count to the bouncing nets thank you i
would like to agree with the speaker
that we had uh before council thomas i
think the idea that we can argue that
this is a massive car park and therefore
shouldn't really is the wrong direction
well in what way is a massive car park
consisting of 22 spaces for a building
of this size this is a tiny car park for
a hotel of this size
and given the nature of the area and
given the
fundamental strain it is already under
in relation if this was an area that had
no parking issues at the moment and yes
you'll get some extra cars on the road
as a result of a hotel that's putting
the area then that would be one thing
but that sure as hell is not the case in
this area this is an area which is
already under major strain in terms of
parking we've already got uh
residents any restrictions on and
parking restrictions in every direction
that you look where
even a relatively
small number of extra cars trying to
park in this area is going to cause is
going to cause an issue
so uh that uh acceptable policy
compliance in relation to the disabled
bit okay that's maybe something to be
looked at in the future
uh but that's not a matter for me that's
a matter for the ruling group elsewhere
um but uh in terms of
this
this this reason for refusal i believe
it's it should remain in this is an area
that is already having severe problems
in terms of parking at
a variety of occasions because
simply because of where it is in
relation to
other facilities within the borough
that's why there are so many
restrictions already in place in this
area okay thank you
any any members wanting to raise any new
points about parking please
cancel hassan
thank you sir parking is a burning issue
in the north of trafford uh mr chair
and how we can ignore it and north of
trafford
is already a dense populous area we are
getting complaints from the residents
every single day about the parking
around the football ground and the
cricket ground it is on the border of
our res my constituency so i am not in
favor of and i will totally against this
parking
will be and it is a mockery 12 story
building
and it's only 23 parking spaces
absolutely not thank you
thank you councillor son so on on the
parking
what what i'd just like to i think
say to try and
clarify things is that the the parking
standards
as i understand it would require one
space per bedroom so
the policy would require a maximum of
169 spaces
um this the the
first application
effectively had none it had one
accessible space and no other parking
spaces
and the
inspector hearing that appeal
um
did uphold the refusal
on parking grounds because he found that
was
insufficient
but what he what he did also say is that
the location is sustainable
and and so it would accommodate less
than the substantially less i think he
said than the than the maximum parking
standard of
169. so for me the issue is um
you know
is 22 spaces sufficient
i don't think it is but the inspector's
clear that it should be substantive it
could be substantially less than 169 and
that would be acceptable um i do agree
with
councillor thomas and councillor bunting
that
you know there are complaints about
parking in that in that area
already and in fact the inspector on the
appeal
does make
comments about
the impact of the inadequate parking
that was obviously considering zero
parking spaces but he does talk about
competition with local residents uh and
he does
talk about
you know the suggested mitigation which
is funding the review of parking
restrictions
fine but
that does tend to push the problem
elsewhere
and
there will be increased competition for
the unrestricted parking that remains so
i think i understand what councillor
minister says and i would love to think
of
more people traveling to hotels like
this um using public transport and and
not not by car
but i think given the location and the
people like to use it either people on
business or people going to the sporting
events
i think an awful lot of them are likely
to arrive by car because
you could you could say this is a
reflection among united fans but they
you know they come from all areas of the
country and
objection
not not not all areas of the country
have have good railings to manchester so
i you know i still think that
the the 22 spaces is is not sufficient
for that reason i would love it to be
otherwise but i do think it's
insufficient regardless of the the
booking system and the valet parking
that the hotel wants to put in place um
so so i still think the the parking is
a reasonable
reason for refusal i think
given its policy compliant in terms of
accessible parking i i would propose
removing the reference to
there being insufficient accessible
parking but
that's where i am on it i think um
councillor morgan did you want to speak
yeah it wasn't about that point i was i
was kind of going to support you i i i i
was going to support cancer at the top
of the council huntington's point before
you articulated your sport for it i i i
think
what we're not saying is by removing
this
it's not
22 spaces or 169 spaces there is a
medium between that and there's a big
gray and it's um you know we
you don't need to have 170 to say to say
that
thank you okay
um
so um
there's been a lot of contributions so i
know i've suggested we we removed the
reference to accessible parking being
sufficient does anyone uh is anyone
agree with me on that
no councillor welton
i'll back you on that if it's policy
compliant then i think we're setting
ourselves up for a full with the piano
inspector thank you okay thank you ken
so it's been moved and seconded that
from the third reason we removed the
reference to um
so it'd be removing the words in
addition the development would provide
insufficient parking space for disabled
persons it would read that sentence
so all those in favor of removing that
sentence please
okay
so that's uh so that's unanimous so we
would take out that that sentence that
refers to the accessible parking
and i don't think anyone has moved that
we
remove anything else or or remove the
whole reason so
just checking so
that reason stands down there's no no
yeah okay so that third reason stands so
um
that brings us to the end of that item
i'm i'm grateful to to members for their
patients and their contributions on that
it's not an easy issue
we'll move on to try and wrap up as soon
as we can to item number eight which is
the
updated planning committee uh code of
practice
um i think we're going to have a
brief introduction from uh
miss coaly thank you
thank you chairman and yes i will be i
will be brief um members will recall the
various uh informal discussions we've
had
um and that have taken place in respect
to this code of practice so this evening
the the final version is presented for
you for your approval uh ahead of
adoption by full council um and if you
do approve it would go forward to full
council later this month for formal
adoption um it reflects changes in
practice and procedure um since it was
originally drafted in 2017
um which are generally now proposed to
be formalized into the into the
constitution and those are laid out for
you in in the report members so um it
will need to it will need a vote to to
approve or or otherwise
thank you
thank you miss curley i'm minded to move
straight to the vote on this because we
did have a discussion
uh about the code of practice uh on the
last occasion um the draft code has been
circulated to committee members and
they've had an opportunity to
to to comment on that um if members are
not happy they're not happy but
i think we effectively we've had the
debate at the last meeting and via email
but councillor thomas i think you
disagree with that
i do i've read i think when we institute
institute go to practice we need to see
more than the draft uh unfortunately i'd
covered at the last meeting so i wasn't
involved in the discussion and frankly
um
there's a little bit of part 3.11
that i'm a little bit
off with the wording but i think the
whole section on cyprus is apart from
six apart from six six is
unworkable i think part of it takes away
the job of a counsellor in visiting
sites
um
making comments and on which way i agree
we shouldn't be doing that we've already
been told tonight by somebody at nine
carnegie court that the officer that
visited expressed an opinion
uh we shouldn't be expressing opinions
and we'll agree with that what we're
told in in in the in the discussion that
uh the officer
said that if it was it was if he was
living there
he would object as well that wasn't the
officer
who was the officer okay
officer okay the ladies said an officer
anyway so but i think
i'm sorry
i think that uh
whilst they agree site visits are are
for observing the cyber council only
viewed aside from public vantage points
but if we are invited in i think there's
no issue with that um site visits should
not be used as loving opportunity we
shouldn't be lobbied anyway but we
should be discussing with people who
have have reasonable objections and make
them clear um invite you on society
about an interesting party
why on earth no we're we're discussing
the
pros and cons of the site we should not
be swayed
by by anything on our meeting i just
don't understand why section six
regarding around site visits is that as
councillors
we are aware that we should not be
giving
any um
[Music]
preference to
to people that we meet on site we're
there to look at
sites and uh in some cases we have no we
cannot do that because they're in back
gardens i can name four
that i have not been able to see because
i can't get access to where the where
the building is supposed to be okay how
can we make a judgment there councilor
thomas
i i don't understand your objection to
what's in the code of practice i
understand what you're saying about site
visits and and and you know not
expressing an opinion like which which
bit of the of the draft code of practice
is is it site visits is the main one to
be honest with you
site because it's the only thing i can i
could say
uh that i agree with is is
site 86.6
which is
to me common sense i worry that if i go
out to
a site
and i am there as a counsellor
and it's in my ward and someone knows me
as a counselor in my award that i'm
somebody comes up and has a discussion
with about with her about me that i
could be breaking the code of practice
i'm very scared of that i also think the
site visits should not be used as a
lobbying opportunity by objectives or
supporters if you are known as a
counsellor
people are going to ask you are we
breaking the code by listening to our
ward residents
no i don't i don't think that's what the
code is is saying councillor thomas and
and
we
we
we have had this debate before i
appreciate you what you weren't here but
we can't keep delaying the decision
until now you want to see your
impression to vote on something that
i've not had anything i am expecting it
yeah and if you don't agree with it
you're entitled to vote against it but
we cannot rerun the same discussion
about the code of practice when we
discussed it at the last committee and
we discussed it by you know and it was
and there was particular
uh discussion i can't remember there's a
meeting or by email about the section on
site visits um and i i don't know if you
want to say any more about that mrs
curley but i
i'm still struggling to understand what
your objection is in in paragraph six do
you my objection is it's a code of
practice and from
six sorry
lots of paid from 6.1
to 6.5
i understand that as doing my duty as a
counsellor in my ward so what's the
difficulty with it any of that is
we're told we can't
the code of practice says that we can't
do that you tell you
you have a different role council thomas
as a member of the planning committee as
a ward councillor
those are separate
things that you have to deal with and
you have to behave as a planning
committee member when you're dealing
with planning committee business but as
a ward councillor in anything else
that you do but if you want to be on
planning committee you have to be a
planning committee member at the
appropriate time fully appreciate that
understand that and i said that before
people who's when you were recognized as
a
ward member that you may get lobbied
when does that break the code of
practice
cancel a minute if i can just briefly
comment on that the whole issue is about
predetermination and predisposition
right so far and yeah you could be but
the important thing is that when you're
considering the on-site visit or the
application you're considering the
application on its merits okay
and there's a big difference between as
it's been quite properly commented on
attending that site visit as a member of
the planning committee
and attending or going as a as the as
the award member and
looking at the application through that
prism okay completely i completely agree
with you
there's nothing in this code that in any
way inhibits you in any way whatsoever
from discharging your responsibilities
as a member of the planning committee
and it's quite entirely reasonable it's
standard this is common practice right
across planning authorities there's
nothing controversial adverse or
inappropriate in any of this guidance at
all first of all
to members in considering this
first off i've not said inappropriate in
any way shape or form what i've said is
i'm uncomfortable with it i'm
uncomfortable with it because it seems
to me that it's taking away the
opportunity for residents to approach me
as a planning member i would not give a
preference to any single person that
asked me what i thought on a site visit
i would look at it i would listen to
what they had to say but i would not
prefer any
uh okay any yeah okay let's open them
let's pause there cancer thomas um i i i
still don't understand why you have a
difficulty with what's in in paragraph
six around site visits because that is
about site visits being made by you
as a member of this committee okay i
don't read that as there's nothing to
stop you going seeing a resident about a
planet i've so i've done this and miss
curly will tell me if i'm i'm gonna
offend the code i've been to see
residents about planning matters uh i've
given them advice about that
some of these matters have come to the
committee and i haven't i haven't sat on
those matters does not stop me doing
that but if i go on a site visit as a
member of this committee
to to view the site in order to help to
inform
the decision of this committee
then what the what the code is saying is
that i shouldn't express an opinion
to anyone that i see uh when i go to the
site and i
and i don't have a i don't have a
difficulty with that because the the
the opinions we express and the
decisions that we make are at the
committee in this room so i don't have
any problem with that it's not saying
you can't speak to them so you can't
acknowledge them
but i think you can go and you can
explain quite clearly to them that
you're there to view the site and you
can't engage in any discussion about the
merits of the application i don't have
any difficulty with that
and i'm not i'm not sure you do so i'm
i'm okay
i don't and i i 100 agree you should not
offer any uh positive or detrimental
effect on any planning application you
view that's common sense to me you
wouldn't do that you wouldn't say to a
an applicant oh well ah you know because
that gives them the impression that
they've swayed you've got a decision i
don't know i just it's the way it's
worded seems to me
that it's it could be prohibitive
that's all
okay
so i i think your objection is you're
worried that this will apply to any
counsellor in whatever capacity they are
visiting a place
as a planning member for example go into
your own ward where you're known as a
counselor and people come and start
asking you questions and start
you can't just say i'm on planning i
can't discuss it with you you can listen
to them but not give them your views in
my opinion okay i i think if you're on
the committee and you're intending to
sit on the committee i think you can say
i can't discuss this with you i think
you can and i do um so i'm i'm conscious
at a time and counselor thomas you know
you've made your position clear but we
but we have
debated this before and i think there's
been plenty of opportunity to to make
comments already
so the proposal is that we approve this
draft code of practice
so it then goes forward to council so
i'd like us to move to the vote on that
now uh is it a point of order cancel the
bunting oh chairman it was simply to
assist in relation to the point that we
have just heard
you all i would do against thomas
my way is yeah i do say that i say you
can tell if you want to tell them what
you think fine but i'm not telling you
what i think and i'm not engaged there
are two other councillors per ward i
direct them here are the two email
addresses here are the telephone numbers
they
counselor duncan and councillor holden
will be more than happy to talk to you
about it you can deflect off in that if
you're at the site you say well i can't
get involved i have to remain impartial
because it comes up later so just just
forward it on okay thank you councillor
bunting let's move to the vote then on
whether we are happy to
approve that
code of practice uh i'm happy to move it
is
second
okay
it's been moved and seconded that we
approved that code of practice um all
those in favor of approving you could
indicate please
okay and i'll oh is that you as well
that's yeah um all those against please
you can abstain okay
so that is carriage so that code
practice uh is approved and we'll we'll
go forward to council for approval uh
we'll move on now to
uh item nine which is the
traffic design guide and traffic design
code um and we'll have a brief uh
introduction to this by miss carly thank
you thank you chair this is a report
that's just coming to you for
information um as a planning committee
as the public consultation on the
traffic design guide and traffic design
code is now underway uh we very much
like members to to get involved uh in in
both of these documents and to give give
us the views uh the uh there's a
questionnaire about there are two
questionnaires on the website a very
detailed one about the design guide and
we've already had some really helpful
comments from members on on that already
and
would would like more um
particularly uh if you've got your own
looking at your own particular areas and
the character and the guidance but for
those
um and and the design guide
questionnaire runs until the 17th of
august and the design code questionnaire
which is a lot more high level and it's
got a bit of a picture around and is is
is meant to be quite uh easy to engage
with and and fun to engage with runs all
the way over the summer we haven't
got a particular end date for that
because it goes with the
um consultation events we've been doing
um which have gone well so far we've had
um
council hartley came to sale last last
saturday and the council patel's helped
us out as well
and they've gone really well uh we've
got one more to go in stratford um
in
on on saturday there's gonna be some
much more targeted consultation in the
autumn where we will go to community
groups we need hard to reach groups but
we would appreciate your your help with
with with getting to to groups that
wouldn't normally engage with with the
planning system but would be uh
interested in doing so for example we do
sometimes struggle with get with
interest from residents in old trafford
so aquila
the same if you if you don't
you know you you tell us that your
residents are interested in design so
those those links in will be really
really helpful um
and we're gonna so we will do that we'll
do a set of workshops and of course
you'll be invited to those as as ward
members and we'll be able to because
this is a policy document you can get as
involved as you want uh your your
position on the planning committee
doesn't doesn't stop you having an
opinion on any of the of that um i'm
happy to take comments or questions um
where there was a briefing the other
night with some of you were at but
otherwise uh it just falls to members to
note the report
thank you miss carly any questions about
that i think as
this has been outlined i'll be
it'll be we're at the early stage of the
process so you know there'll be more
opportunity to for consultation
certainly encourage
uh members to to provide input cancel
the proctor i know you have already and
those really useful comments councillor
thomas yeah is there a deck on the
meeting i was on holiday so i couldn't
does everybody want that i can send that
round yeah sure yeah absolutely
okay thank you yeah i definitely
encourage you to have a read of that and
have a read of the design guide is it is
long but it's definitely worth uh
reading particularly particularly a bit
about um you know the area where your
award is located because you know your
awards and and you'll know how that's
described um
and uh councillor maitland
really briefly is it easy to access on
the internet
sorry the the link is in the report
it's www designing trafford dot co dot
uk takes you to all of it
thank you
okay thank you uh council proctor
thank you i've only just noticed this
about the guide it's using a serif font
for all the headlines
it shouldn't be doing that
twitter bits on on so something like
times new roman it's difficult to read
if you've got a visual impairment we
should be using tahoma or ariel i could
confirm that the document will be made
fully accessible before it's finally
published we've already got uh
arrangements in place for that i didn't
realize that thing about the serif font
but thank you for that yeah
thank you and i'd encourage everybody to
go through your own words bits because
two of the photos purporting to be
in um some flicks and debuting we're
actually in timperley
yeah because they want to come to m41s
but but
yeah
check
fabulous yeah
have a look at your definitely your area
and the photos because some of the
photos um are not great and if you've
got better examples of what you consider
good design then then uh do feed that
back and we can take photos or you can
take photos yourself um
and uh so that report is for it's for
noting and i think we do they noted that
um last item is uh any urgent business
and i don't think there is any uh so
with that i'll declare a meeting closed
thank you
sorry
to catch my trade that's fine no no you
rush yeah yeah